une rencontre ses homologues notamment
les homologues en matière de santé qui
sont frontalier de l'italie
il apparaît de façon évidente que la
coordination au niveau européen est
indispensable pour faire face à la crise
et j'observe monsieur le député que la
france a été le premier pays de l'union
européenne a souhaité qu'une
coordination européenne s'effectue on
est un petit peu à côté des compétences
traditionnelles de l'union européenne
mais on voit bien que s'agissant de la
libre circulation des personnes
et s'agissant de la coordination des
actions il est indispensable de pouvoir
se parler et prendre des décisions en
commun
c'est ce qu'a fait la france dès le
début de l'épidémie est en avance sur
ses partenaires et je me réjouis
qu'olivier ferrand soit aujourd'hui à
rome pour pouvoir avancer en la matière
vous indiquez à juste titre que cette ce
risque d'épidémie impose une
coordination parfaite et une information
transparente
c'est ce que nous faisons et vous savez
monsieur le député que tous les jours un
point presse est tenue au ministère des
solidarités la santé soit par le
directeur général en charge du sujet
soit par là et ensuite le ministre qui
expose de la façon la plus précise
possible les faits les incertitudes car
je pense qu'il est aussi important de
dire ce que nous ne savons pas que ce
que nous savons et les mesures que nous
prenons
dans le même souci de transparence je
peux vous indiquer que j'ai adressé
aujourd'hui à l'ensemble des maires de
france aux présidents des conseils
départementaux et des conseils régionaux
un courrier indiquant les mesures que
nous avions prises et l'état de nos
connaissances au jour où je parle et en
disant cela monsieur le député je
préfère être parfaitement clair nos
connaissances évoluent forcément au fur
et à mesure des jours qui passent et
nous devons évidemment pour faire face à
ce problème être réactif et prendre au
fur et à mesure les décisions qui
s'imposent
un mot peut-être sur notre état de
préparation
d'abord pour souligner que dès
l'apparition du virus en chine
nous avons organisé avec l'accord des
autorités chinoises est en bonne
intelligence avec les autorités
chinoises le rapatriement d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens vers le
territoire national et nous en avons
profité à la demande des pays européens
pour procéder au rapatriement d'un
certain nombre de citoyens européens
dans le même mouvement
de l'avis général les opérations de
rapatriement ont été remarquablement
organisée je ne le dis pas pour m'en
satisfaire au titre du chef de
gouvernement
je le dis parce que cela veut dire que
les services de l'état que les élus
locaux concernés que l'ensemble de ceux
qui ont contribué à ces opérations ont
fait un remarquable travail et je tiens
à les féliciter
de la même façon monsieur le député de
la même façon monsieur le député il faut
saluer le remarquable travail qui a été
réalisé par les services de santé par
les services administratifs et par les
élus locaux
lorsque des cas ont été identifiés aux
contamines montjoie là aussi de l'avis
général les opérations ont été
remarquablement conduite et nous devons
le dire non pas pour garantir qu'il n'y
aura jamais de problème mais pour se
dire que le système français est
vigilant et alerte face à ces sujets
dernière chose monsieur le député nous
avons veillé à ce que le dispositif
français soit prêt cela passe par la
mise en vigilance d'un certain nombre de
centres hospitaliers
d'abord les chu puis 70 centres
supplémentaires ce qui veut dire que
partout en france où il ya un service de
sa bulle nous sommes prêts à accueillir
d'éventuels malade nous constatons qu'il
n'y a aucun malade hospitalisé en france
aujourd'hui atteints par ce virus
aucun aucun aucun à ce stade mais bien
évidemment nous sommes vigilants et nous
ferons toujours la transparence complexe
et incertain c'est une condition
indispensable de la confiance de nos
concitoyens vous me demandez j'en
termine pardon je suis un peu long mais
je pense que le sujet mérite qu'on soit
complet vous m'interrogez sur
l'éventuelle réunion que nous pourrions
organiser à matignon avec les présidents
des partis politiques et des groupes
j'y suis bien entendu disposer dans le
même esprit que le courrier que j'ai
adressé à l'ensemble des maires des
présidents de conseils départementaux et
des présidents de conseils régionaux
je me tient évidemment à la disposition
pour organiser avec l'ensemble des
présidents et des groupes
je pense que monsieur le député vous
l'avez entendu l'ensemble des présidents
de partis politiques et des groupes
parlementaires
une réunion pour dire très exactement où
nous en sommes en ayant conscience que
la situation exigera des mesures au fur
et à mesure que nous en saurons plus
merci monsieur de premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur le président à bad
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
une seule question se pose aujourd'hui
allez-vous en matière de retraite
utiliser le 49-3 oui ou non
merci monsieur le président parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le président à bad merci pour
votre question a le mérite d'être simple
éclair et écouter la réponse je ne suis
pas sûr d'être aussi con si dans ma
réponse que vous l'avez été dans votre
question et je vais essayer d'être aussi
clair monsieur le président abbas vous
le savez le président de la république
puis la majorité se sont engagés à
mettre en oeuvre un système universel de
retraite par répartition et parfois et
vous le savez monsieur le président la
bad
c'est un projet ambitieux compliqué
discuter contestées je le dis nous en
parlons sérieusement il est contesté il
est discuté c'est bien naturel
après avoir beaucoup travaillé après
avoir beaucoup discuté
nous en sommes au moment où l'assemblée
nationale est saisi d'un projet de loi
par construction il fait l'objet
d'opposition et de proposition
d'amendement
c'est légitime c'est comme ça que les
choses doivent se passer à l'assemblée
nationale bien entendu j'observe
monsieur le président à bab que depuis
maintenant plus de huit jours que le
projet de loi est ici présenté à
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale a consacré beaucoup de son
temps à la discussion de l'esprit de la
réforme
peut-être mais aussi 9 heures à la
discussion de l'intitulé du titre 1 et
un temps considérable à se poser la
question de savoir s'il fallait
remplacer les termes considérant paru
égard annuellement par chaque année où
chaque année par annuellement et que le
temps consacré à ces échanges
parfaitement respectable que je ne
conteste pas le temps passé à ces
échanges ne me paraît pas porté sur le
sens profond d'une réforme ambitieuse
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
autrement dit monsieur le président
abbas mon sujet mon ambition c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte que le
débat ait lieu qu'il soit le plus
sérieux le plus approfondi et ne le
prenez pas en aucune façon comme une
critique mais collectivement le plus
intelligente possible pour qu'il est
justement sa fonction éminente qui
revient au parlement
c'est à dire de faire la loi je le dis
comme je le pense
mais si ça n'est pas possible si au bout
de très nombreuses heures de débats nous
constatons que ça n'est pas possible
alors la constitution alors la
constitution monsieur abad et monsieur
le président vous le savez parfaitement
autorise le cas échéant le premier
ministre a utilisé un article le 49 3 ça
s'est déjà vu dans le passé j'ai un
souvenir précis j'ai un souvenir précis
monsieur le président à bad d'edouard
balladur premier ministre faisant
obstacle à de l'obstruction en utilisant
le 49 3 et j'ai le souvenir précis
monsieur le président à bad de jean
pierre raffarin premier ministre
utilisant le 49-3 exactement pour faire
en sorte que le débat puisse avancer et
qu'il ne soit pas stérilisés et je suis
sûr monsieur le président à bad que vous
vous en souvenez aussi bien que moi
autrement dit monsieur le président à
bâle
bâle lorsqu'il faut prendre ses
responsabilités je le fais sans hésiter
et j'utilise tout la constitution rien
que la constitution mais bien toute la
constitution il appartient monsieur le
président à l'assemblée nationale elle
même de faire vivre ce débat
si ce débat vie et qu'il permet
d'avancer dans de bonnes conditions tant
mieux c'est ce que je souhaite mais à
partir d'un certain moment il faut être
clair nous nous sommes engagés sur ce
système universel de retraite par
répartition et par point et l'engagement
du gouvernement le fait majoritaire
ça existe
celui non
chiche mais je messieurs écoutez le
président abad
il a la parole monsieur le premier
ministre
depuis quelques jours le rythme des
amendements est un rythme classique dans
la procédure parlementaire et vous le
savez très bien monsieur le premier
ministre vous le savez très bien
aujourd'hui vous ne fermait pas la porte
aux 49 3 et les français doivent mesurer
toutes les conséquences de l'utilisation
de ce 49 3 le 49 3 c'est le passage en
force sans vote
le 49 3 c'est un texte qui sera adopté
et qui n'est pas financé le 49-3 c'est
aussi le fait tout simplement que des
centaines de questions sur les
agriculteurs sur la pénibilité sur les
carrières longues et autres resteront
sans réponse et monsieur le premier
ministre
soyons clairs jamais jamais la droite
n'a utilisé le 49-3 pour la réforme des
retraites en 93 en 2003 ou en 2010 et
vous le savez parfaitement aujourd'hui
et il existe une alternative cherche à
karachi
c'est notre proposition de résolution
qui vous fait une profession très clair
mettez un nouveau texte sur la table
financé complet en temps législatif
programmé et qui évitera toute
obstruction parlementaire parce que les
français en ont assez
entre d'un côté les insoumis qui veulent
bloquer de l'autre les indignés de la
majorité qui refuse le débat de fond et
ils vous renvoient donc deux ados et il
regrette ce spectacle désolant d'une
guérilla parlementaire qui est devenu
irresponsables qui est devenu
inconséquente et qui tout simplement est
devenue incompréhensible
eh bien nous les républicains on a fait
le choix du débat sérieux et responsable
alors monsieur premier revenez à la
raison respecter le parlement ait refusé
le 49-3 merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
quelques remarques rapide monsieur le
président puisque il m'est possible de
vous répondre
d'abord pour vous dire que j'entends ce
que vous dites du débat actuel et vous
êtes très critique sur sa qualité et
donc sur l'obstruction que vous dénoncez
j'entends que vous faites une
proposition est à lire parfaitement
respectable pour avancer je le salue
même cette proposition elle a un
inconvénient majeur à mon sens monsieur
le président abbas
c'est que elle renvoie l'adoption de ce
texte à 2021
mécaniquement pour une raison très
simple mécaniquement pour une raison
très simple qui est tenu et lié au
calendrier parlementaire
or il se trouve monsieur le président à
bad que nous souhaitons que cette
réforme soit adoptée de façon à rentrer
en vigueur dans ses effets positifs à
partir du 1er janvier 2022 et que là
dessus nous sommes engagés et que nous
tiendrons cet engagement et je me
permets monsieur abad
monsieur le président pardon de vous
dire que la charge que vous venez de
livrer contre l'utilisation du 49 3 oui
parce que la constitution est sans doute
indiqué qu'ils avaient des sujets sur
lesquels on n'avait pas le droit de
faire du 49 3 et puis des sujets sur
lesquels on aurait la charge à laquelle
vous vous livrez sur la constitution sur
l'article 49-3 sur la constitution de
1958 singulièrement venue de ces bancs
me surprend et je la déplore
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole à monsieur philippe la tombe
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale les épreuves du contrôle
continu du baccalauréat a dit que trois
c ont pour vocation d'inciter les élèves
à travailler plus régulièrement et de
permettre une évaluation plus juste de
leur niveau effectif
l'obtention du baccalauréat ne se joue
donc plus uniquement sur une seule
épreuve par matière et récompense un
travail sérieux et régulier sur deux ans
cependant cette première édition d o3sis
s'est déroulée pour quelques
établissements seulement et heureusement
dans un climat de grande tension et de
contestation les lycéens se sont plaints
de la surcharge de travail de la
pression constante de la mauvaise
préparation mais surtout de l'inégalité
de traitement entre les candidats
puisque les mêmes épreuves n'était
programmé en même temps pour tout le
monde
les professeurs incrimine aussi les
changements constants des programmes et
des sujets qui pénalise fortement le
travail de préparation les informations
sur les modalités de l'examen reçu
tardivement et au compte gouttes et à
certain autisme des services
ministériels face à leurs
questionnements les proviseurs quant à
eux se plaignent d'avoir à assurer à la
fois l'organisation la surveillance le
secrétariat la numérisation des copies
des candidats tout en faisant face à un
mécontentement voire aux débordements
des élèves des professeurs et des
parents d'élèves
parmi les couacs relevé par exemple on
peut noter la numérisation en noir et
blanc des cartes de géographie réalisé
en couleur par les élèves est donc
impossible à noter par les correcteurs
ce désarroi à dans certains
établissements tourné à la colère et
certaines épreuves n'ont pas pu se
dérouler en raison du blocus
les résultats de ces trois c'est devant
être intégrés au fur et à mesure dans
parcours sup se pose donc la question de
la notation des élèves qui n'ont pas
voulu ou pu composer
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quelles solutions vous
envisagez pour corriger ces
dysfonctionnements observés à l'occasion
de cette première édition des 3 c afin
de mener à bien une réforme dont le
modem soutient par ailleurs les
objectifs
je vous remercie monsieur de député la
parole de monsieur jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député philippe la tombe
merci d'abord d'avoir rappelé le sens du
contrôle continu n'existe pas pour rien
il est là pour permettre un travail
continu des élèves dès le début de la
classe de première et jusqu'à la
terminale pour éviter le bas tout le
bachotage de fin de parcours
et c'est vrai aussi pour avoir une plus
grande authenticité de la notation
au moment où dans parcours super cette
notation jouent un rôle pour la suite et
si c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
grande cohérence entre la réforme
parcours super la réforme du
baccalauréat
c'est une des raisons vous faites
mention de perturbations vous avez dit
très brièvement au début de votre propos
que c'était le fait d'établissement
minoritaires je rappelle que dans 85%
des cas ça s'est bien passé et
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
sur un million sept cent mille copies
attendu en a plus d'un million six cent
mille dont l'immense majorité a déjà été
corrigé
corrigés et vous l'avez dit sous un
angle négatif mais je voudrais insister
sous l'angle positif grâce à la
numérisation la numérisation est une
innovation extrêmement intéressante
elle permet en particulier aux élèves de
pouvoir regarder leur correction sur
internet d'ici quelques semaines au
moment où tout sera prêt c'est donc
quelque chose de totalement inédit qui
fait aussi évoluer le travail en équipe
aussi bien en amont pour choisir les
sujets que en aval pour regarder
l'harmonisation des corrections
il ya toute une série de progrès qui
sont liées à cette réforme du contrôle
continu et nous nous en réjouissons
bien entendu il ya aussi des
imperfections rien n'est jamais parfait
et je suis donc très ouvert pour les
évolutions de ce qu'on appelle les yeux
3 c il y aura une deuxième session de 3
c d'ici à la fin de l'année scolaire
nous avons vous le savez un comité de
suivi du baccalauréat ce comité de suivi
rassemble notamment les organisations
représentatives et va nous permettre
probablement d'aller vers plus de
simplification pour remédier à certains
des problèmes que vous avez mentionné
puisque le but c'est évidemment la
bienveillance vis-à-vis des élèves et
une préparation en continu en tout cas
les retours que nous avons de la part de
ceux qui l'ont fait sans perturbations
sont des retours très positifs quant au
niveau des élèves quand halak ou quant
au fait qu'ils ont été beaucoup plus au
travail depuis le mois de septembre
merci bon merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et à monsieur le président
andré chassaigne monsieur le premier
ministre la réforme des retraites que
vous avez engagé tourne au fiasco
à chaque étape vous êtes confrontés à
l'échec
son annonce a déclenché un mouvement
social inédit depuis le début de la vème
république un profond rejet dans
l'opinion les partenaires sociaux dans
toute leur diversité reste extrêmement
critique
le conseil d'état dans un avis
extrêmement sévère alerte sur son
insécurité juridique vos études d'impact
et fallacieuse votre texte comporte
aujourd'hui plus de 30 ordonnance dont
les contours sont excessivement large
la procédure accélérée a été déclenchée
malgré le désaccord de toutes les
oppositions la commission spéciale a été
interrompue à voir la fin de ces travaux
quant à la présidence de notre assemblée
elle a tenté autoritairement et
inconstitutionnellement de supprimer
déjà maman de l'opposition sans notre
révolte des milliers d'amendements
n'aurait pu être discutée la majorité ce
rhdp d'une prétendue obstruction ne
supportant pas le véritable débat
démocratique que nous avons initié et
qu'elle voulait éviter à tout prix parce
que ce débat engagé grâce aux
oppositions met en exergue les
nombreuses questions de fond questions
auxquelles vous n'êtes pas capables de
répondre vous à verdi votre attachement
à cette réforme
mais pourquoi monsieur le premier
ministre vous enfermer dans un
calendrier lié aux élections
pourquoi vous bloquez sur une date
butoir qui crée les conditions d'une
adoption profondément antidémocratique
monsieur le premier ministre
imaginez-vous qu'une réforme qui réécrit
notre pacte social
puis ainsi être traité ainsi être
liquidée nous vous appelons une fois
encore sous la neige main solennellement
à retirer ce texte pour créer les
conditions d'un débat serein dans le
pays
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et monsieur le
président chassaigne vous connaissez
trop bien l'histoire politique française
pour savoir qu'un certain nombre de
textes fondateurs y compris de notre
dispositif sociales ou de santé ont
résulté ordonnance ce fut le cas en 1958
fait en 1958 y avait unanimité monsieur
le président chasse n
je ne crois pas et du reste vos
prédécesseurs sur ses bancs ne portait
pas ceux qui portaient ces réformes 1958
dans leur coeur et il n'y avait pas
d'unanimité vous le savez très bien
monsieur le président ça c'est non quand
même soyons sérieux
ouais bah oui d'accord mais peut-être
mais en 1958 qui a eu des ordonnances
vous le savez parfaitement et il me
semble qu'elles sont un tout petit peu
essentiel c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
s'agissant de l'organisation du
dispositif de santé ou de la sécurité
sociale monsieur le président chasse
aide nous nous sommes engagés et c'est
parfaitement démocratique nous nous
sommes engagés le président de la
république au moment des présidentielles
la majorité au moment des législatives
sur un projet sur un projet clair un
système universel de retraite par
répartition et par point il est
parfaitement
il est parfaitement entendable monsieur
le président chassé m
que vous soyez opposé un système
universel de même il est parfaitement
entendable que certains soit opposé un
système par points
ils se trouvent monsieur le président sa
chaîne chassaigne pardon que c'est le
projet qui a été porté par la majorité
c'est le projet que nous avons travaillé
c'est un projet qui nous paraît apporter
des garanties de progrès social
considérable de solidité du financement
de ce système considérable et la vérité
monsieur le président chassaigne c'est
que si en 1945 comme c'était
initialement prévu
le système véritablement universel et
égale avait été construit personne ici
aujourd'hui n'essaieraient de le
saucissonner en quarante deux régimes
souvent peu équilibrée et qui veut mars
en fonction de transferts financiers
d'autres personnes c'est ça la vérité
monsieur le président chassaigne est ça
la vérité est donc 7
majorité et le gouvernement sont engagés
dans cette réforme
ils ont soumis au parlement un projet de
loi il est discuté tant mieux mais enfin
monsieur le président vous ne pouvez pas
dire vous ne pouvez pas dire que les
dizaines de milliers d'amendements
souvent répétitifs qui n'ont au fond
aucune espèce d'impact sur le faux
serait déposée pour autre chose que
ralentir voire même empêcher l'examen
commission spéciale c'est une tactique
parlementaire elle et entendent abl mais
elle ne sert pas la qualité du débat
c'est profondément mon avis et je crois
que c'est profondément la vie des
français merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole est à monsieur
thierry benoit merci mon cher président
madame la ministre du commerce madame
agnès pannier rue nash et cette semaine
se tient le salon de l'agriculture c'est
aussi la fin des négociations
commerciales et ce sont les premières du
genre qui s'applique pleinement dans le
cadre de la loi fixe et la loi et galim
tout le monde s'accorde à dire qu'à ce
stade le bilan et gally mais plutôt
contrasté concernant la rémunération des
agriculteurs
madame la ministre pendant six mois avec
une trentaine de députés dont le député
grégory besson moreau rapporteur nous
avons enquêté sur la nature des
relations commerciales entre producteurs
industriels et distributeurs
le constat est implacable depuis dix ans
la guerre des prix fait des ravages
cet état de tension n'existe nulle part
ailleurs la valeur ajoutée créée par les
producteurs s'est déplacé de l'amont
vers l'aval au profit des distributeurs
mais aussi de certains industriels
il y a urgence à mettre de l'ordre dans
les négociations commerciales
madame la ministre le rapport de la
commission denquête a été adoptée en
septembre dernier à l'unanimité des
députés représentant l'ensemble des
groupes de l'assemblée nationale le
gouvernement est il prêt aujourd'hui à
traduire ses propositions en actes tout
d'abord encadrer les pratiques des
centrales service 2000 signé en suisse
jcs au luxembourg ensuite soumettent les
regroupements des centrales d'achat à
autorisation préalable
ensuite lutter contre les pâtes les
pratiques commerciales abusives
enfin renforcer les moyens de contrôle
de l'autorité de la concurrence et de la
dgccrf
en définitive le gouvernement madame la
ministre du commerce entente il replace
et les agriculteurs et les produits
agricoles au coeur des négociations
commerciales
je vous remercie merci monsieur les buts
et la parole et à madame agnès b mme
irina chez secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député benoist merci de
mettre en lumière ce sujet des relations
entre distributeurs et industriels et
producteurs qui est effectivement très
important et qui a une actualité
particulière au moment du salon de
l'agriculture
car le constat que vous avez fait dans
votre mission avec monsieur le
rapporteur besson moreau est un constat
que nous avons partagés c'est le même
constat qui nous a conduits à organiser
les états généraux de l'alimentation qui
nous a conduits à adopter collectivement
dans cette assemblée la loi et galim et
à mettre en place des mesures qui
aujourd'hui tendent à rééquilibrer les
relations entre distributeurs
industriels et agriculteurs et je veux
revenir sur ces actions vous demandez si
nous suivons effectivement ces relations
bien entendu puisque nous avons un suivi
mensuel des négociations qui sont
actuellement en cours avec des
ajustements très régulier des lignes de
la dgccrf sur l'encadrement des
promotions par exemple deuxième élément
est ce que nous encadrons les pratiques
des centrales service des missiles ya
les étrangers je vous rappeler ici il
enquête de la dgccrf qui a conduit à
l'assignation devant le juge de leclerc
pour ses pratiques deux centrales
services à l'étranger avec une amende à
la clef de 117 millions d'euros je crois
qu'aucun gouvernement n'était allée est
activement aussi loin et avec autant de
détermination
sur ce sujet je veux également rappelé
rappeler les 5500 contrôles menés par la
dgccrf l'année dernière et je crois que
sur les luttes contre les pratiques
commerciales abusives au travers de l'
ordonnance du 24 avril 2019 tout ça mais
également nous avons renforcé les moyens
enfin la loi et gagne prévoit un
contrôle ex post renforcée par
l'autorité de la concurrence et je veux
vous dire ici que trois contrôles sont
d'ores et déjà menées et que nous allons
continuer dans ce sens au service des
agriculteurs
merci la parole est à monsieur eric
coquerel cette question cette question
concerne monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre depuis
plusieurs jours le groupe en marche à
l'assemblée explique être prêt à
soutenir l'utilisation par votre
gouvernement du 49 3 cette soumission
serait inédite un groupe politique
pourtant majoritaires à l'assemblée
supplie d'utiliser l'outil le plus anti
parlementaire qui existent dans le pays
le 49 3 a toujours ou quasi toujours été
utilisé par un gouvernement peu sûr de
sa majorité certains parlementaires de
la majorité reproche même à l'opposition
d'exister
l'examen du texte serait trop chère
distille l'opposition que vous détestez
a pourtant été très utile sans elle les
français ne seraient même pas que leur
retraite sera calculé à partir d'un
indicateur qui n'existe même pas sans
elle de nombreuses professions aurait
été trahi
sans même le savoir comme les
agriculteurs ou les professeurs
contrairement à la propagande que vous
déversez dans les médias en une semaine
la france a soumise par exemple n'a
défendu que 200 amendements mais pour
chaque prise de parole de l'opposition
on compte une intervention waouh 1 de
votre majorité
c'est l'obstruction par la pleurniche
tout ça uniquement pour respecter un
calendrier en fonction de vos intérêts
électoraux vous voulez qu'on abatte 70
ans d'histoire sociale en deux semaines
c'est comme vouloir faire rentrer un
éléphant dans un entonnoir
monsieur le premier je dirais entendu
votre réponse à monsieur haddad
manifestement sous la pression de votre
majorité vous
visage et d'utiliser le 49-3 comme un
chantage en décidant de la façon dont
l'opposition doit se comporter
je veux vous éviter ce qui serait à pas
supplémentaire dans une dérive
autoritaire
je vous propose donc date monsieur le
premier ministre
d'attendre les résultats de la
conférence de financement cela ferait
sept à huit semaines de débats moins que
la privatisation tf1
rien de trop pour une loi telle
importance je lui ai proposé pour
insoumise d'autres groupes ont suivi
sans réponse de votre part monsieur le
premier ministre
êtes vous prêt à accepter ces
propositions qui seraient une solution
plus digne que 49 3 merci monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur laurent
prête pietrasinski secrétaire d'état
chargé des retraites
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
eric coquerel
nous travaillons ensemble depuis de
nombreuses heures salle ont pu constater
à la fois en commission spéciale pendant
près de 10 jours mais également dans cet
hémicycle depuis plus d'une semaine que
nous travaillons sur des dizaines des
milliers d'amendements voire de
sous-amendements et maintenant
d'ailleurs principalement de votre
groupe pour lequel nous cherchons à
savoir s'il a des reculs doit être
placée avant ou après le mot s'il faut
remplacer un adverbe par un autre voilà
est donc évidemment ces sujets là ces
sujets là ne font pas progresser le
débat et ne nous emmène pas sur le fond
d'ailleurs je voulais moi même dit à
plusieurs reprises alors la vraie
question tu peux être posée c'est à quoi
servent tous ses amendements si ce n'est
à ralentir le débat et à l'empêcher
vous vous avez réussi à organiser de
longs tunnels d'expression en déposant
des dizaines de sous amendements qui
n'ont pas été d'ailleurs si j'ai bien
compris du goût de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale puisqu'il ya
d'autres positions que la vôtre et j'ai
entendu d'ailleurs ici le groupe et leur
exprimer son souhait de travailler sur
le fond et qu'ils avaient bien du mal à
le faire puisque vous passiez votre
temps vous essayez
de changer des virgules ou de changer
des adverbes alors je vous invite
monsieur député coquerel à réfléchir aux
volumes d'amendements que vous avez
déposé
ce volume d'amendements qui empêche la
représentation nationale de travailler
sur le fond elles le font c'est quoi
monsieur le député eric coquerel
c'est un projet un projet de justice
sociale un projet qui vise à
reconstruire à reconstruire la
solidarité entre les générations a donné
les droits nouveaux internet voir
traiter dès 2022 d'avoir un minimum de
pension à 1000 euros donc revenir à 5
millions de femmes une majoration de
pension
tu es le premier enfant voilà la réalité
du projet que nous vous proposons et que
je vous invite dès tout à l'heure 18
heures à discuter sur le fond dans cet
hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame valérie thomas
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
ministre
l'épidémie de coronavirus qu'ovide 19
gagne du terrain chaque jour un peu plus
depuis le mois de décembre et les
premiers cas apparus en chine et malgré
une mobilisation importante des acteurs
en santé mondiale notamment de l'om est
ce cette épidémie ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur
le week-end dernier c'est l'italie qui
s'est retrouvé touché de plein fouet
plusieurs villes se retrouvent isolés
plus de 250 personnes sont infectées et
plusieurs décès sont à déplorer
faisant de l'italie le pays le plus
touché d'europe les foyers infectieux se
retrouve désormais en corée du sud au
japon en iran et dans plusieurs autres
pays
la liste s'accroît de jour en jour le
bilan aujourd'hui fait état de plus de
80 mille personnes contaminées et près
de 2700 morts
cela a été rappelé le monde est
désormais dans un mode de passage en
transmission communautaire ce qui rend
le contrôle beaucoup plus difficile et
laisse présager un risque d'introduction
à partir d'autres foyers que la chine
l'ensemble des forces de notre pays
chercheurs médecins personnels de santé
sont mobilisés pour répondre au
développement de la maladie en france
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer leur
engagement et rappeler que notre système
est très probablement un des plus
performants au monde pour répondre à
l'urgence le ministre d santé et des
solidarités olivier ferrand est
totalement mobilisé sur cette question
et se trouve actuellement à rome nous le
savons alors que certaines et certains
tentent de lancer des polémiques
irresponsable
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
indiquer à ce jour le nombre de
personnes impactées par le virus dans
notre pays
pouvez vous nous faire part du plan qui
pourrait être déployé en france
si les cas de personnes porteuses du coc
vite venait à se multiplier et il
notamment prévu d'isoler des parties de
notre territoire avec des foyers
si madame la députée la parlotte à
monsieur n'dri attaquer
terres d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
madame la députée valérie thomas la
situation en france est stable depuis le
24 janvier 2020 12 cas d'infection au
corona virus ont été détectés dans notre
pays aujourd'hui 25 février onze
patients sont désormais guéri il n'ya
donc à ce jour par d'épidémie en france
et le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé l'ensemble des services de
l'état l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé sont pleinement mobilisées pour
que la situation reste maîtrisée pour
être en mesure d'agir le moment venu
c'est important de le rappeler car notre
stratégie est fonction du niveau de
risque elle est surtout comme le
rappelait le premier ministre adaptable
et révisable à tout moment et tout est
mis en place pour freiner aujourd'hui
l'introduction dû virus sur le trait sur
le territoire par le dépistage des cas
possibles notamment
nous avons augmenté nos capacités
diagnostic par l' isolement des malades
ou encore par le contact tracing comme
nous l'avons fait aux contamines
montjoie qui est un cas d'école
au dire de tout le monde si demain le
virus commencé à circuler en france
c'est à dire avec des transmissions que
nous n'arrivions plus à expliquer alors
nous pourrions être amenés à prendre des
décisions pour atténuer les effets d'une
vague épidémique
comme précédemment évoqués par le
premier ministre le plan horse and trade
qui doit permettre de prendre en charge
les patients y compris en cas d'épidémie
a été activités activé pardon par
l'ensemble des agences régionales de
santé dès le 11 février dernier en lien
avec le premier ministre le ministre des
solidarités de la santé olivier ferrand
a décidé d'activer 70 établissements
siège d'un samu pour augmenter nos
capacités de réponse contre 38 jusqu'à
présent madame la députée vous pouvez
évidemment compter sur la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des acteurs afin de
continuer à éviter tout risque pour
notre pays nos citoyens nos concitoyens
doivent être rassurés et confiants à ce
sujet je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parade est
un monsieur eric ciotti
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
associer à ma question collègue émilie
bonnivard député de savoie cette
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre le monde connaît depuis
quelques semaines une crise sanitaire
majeure cela a été dit c'est désormais
l'europe qui est touchée avec cette
flambée qui a affecté l'italie voisine
depuis vendredi où 3 cas de corona virus
avait été détecté nous sommes à ce jour
quelques jours plus tard à 300 cas c'est
donc une flambée qui touche l'italie et
c'est une flambée qui inquiète les
départements frontaliers voisin qui
aujourd'hui sont traversés par par le
doute
nous avons dans le département des
alpes-maritimes principales portes
d'entrée de l'italie en france de fortes
inquiétudes et ses inquiétudes sont
renforcées par le sentiment unanimement
partagée par les élus d'un temps de
retard dans la réponse ce week end
alors nous attendons aujourd'hui
monsieur le premier ministre que des
mesures des actes très précis et que je
vais vous rappeler soient mises en
oeuvre ces actes c'est d'abord
l'activation du plan pandémie tel qu'il
avait été instaurée par le gouvernement
de nicolas sarkozy
en 2011 ces actes se sont également une
information systématique de toutes les
personnes qui traversent la frontière
franco-italienne les frontières qu'elles
soient portuaires aéroportuaires ou
terrestre mais c'est aussi la
possibilité de mettre en place un
contrôle seat celle à misano est
aujourd'hui en tout cas jusqu'à hier
rien n'avait été fait
seat se sont aussi la mise en place de
détecteurs de fièvre ces actes se sont
aussi la mise en place de tests au chu
de nice alors qu'ils sont renvoyées
jusqu'à lundi prochain
monsieur le premier ministre le pire
n'est jamais certain mais nous avons le
devoir de nous préparer au pire et en la
matière un principe de précaution
s'impose même si jusqu'à ce jour
france a été relativement douce à
monsieur le député il se donna karan
l'état monsieur adrien taquet secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député ciotti nous
suivons évidemment avec grande attention
l'évolution de la situation en italie
les personnes revenant de lombardie ou
de vénétie font l'objet des mêmes
recommandations sanitaires que pour les
personnes revenant de chine
le ministre olivier véran vous le savez
ça a été évoqué au moment où je vous
parle à rome avec les ministres de la
santé des pays voisins afin de
déterminer les prochaines étapes de la
coopération européenne en termes de
surveillance épidémiologique et les
mesures sanitaires à prendre pour
assurer la sécurité sanitaire de nos
ressortissants qui en découleront nous
sommes donc en lien étroit vous le savez
monsieur le député avec nos voisins
européens afin d'agir ensemble pour
faire face aux hauts risques
ep 10 mai car vous le savez fermer une
frontière terrestre en tant que tel
n'aurait n'aurait pas de sens et ne
seraient pas suffisantes nous nous
concentrons sur les mesures qui marche
les mesures qui marche comme la mise en
place du plan one reb que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure avec a permis
l'activation de 70 établissements siège
d'un samu pour augmenter nos capacités
de réponse
et concernant plus précisément les alpes
maritimes
vous le savez là aussi monsieur le
député sous le pilotage du préfet des
alpes maritimes un comité de suivi de
départementale a été mise en place
réunissant autour la délégation
territoriale de l'agencé régionale de
santé et de l'autorité préfectorale
l'ensemble des services de l'état
concernés le chu de nice que vous
évoquiez le conseil départemental et les
principales communes du département et
dites moi et sauf erreur vous avez
participé vous même à ces réunions un
groupe de contact au demeurant a été
mise en place un groupe de contact
permanent qui a été monté entre la
préfecture des alpes-maritimes la
préfecture dit mme périat en italie et
le consulat honoraire de france à
victime il est monsieur le député vous
pouvez compter sur l'ensemble des
acteurs sanitaires français mobilisés au
quotidien sur le terrain comme sur notre
coopération et la solidarité européenne
pour protéger les françaises et les
français que ce soit l'occasion pour moi
c'est l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé qui veille à la sécurité sanitaire
de nos congénères si monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur éric pouliot
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise à l'intérieur
à l'occasion d'un déplacement à mulhouse
mardi dernier le président de la
république a annoncé des mesures fortes
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
islamistes le président a insisté sur un
axe qui me paraît fondamental le soutien
aux initiatives culturelles éducatives
et associatives sur le terrain car
lutter contre le séparatisme c'est avant
tout ramener tous nos concitoyens dans
le giron républicain s'est rassemblée
notre pays autour des valeurs qui font
notre fierté à tous la liberté l'égalité
et la fraternité
la réponse va donc être globale est
avant tout social et culturel
il est de notre devoir de ramener la
république partout où elle a pu disons
le clairement s'effacer lorsque j'ai
travaillé avec mon collègue eric diard
sur la radicalisation dans les services
publics l'an passé nous avons constaté à
quel point cette approche permet de
dépasser les tabous de déconstruire les
amalgames et de renouer le dialogue avec
tous les français
monsieur le ministre alors que le
président de la république reçoit
aujourd'hui les associations à l'elysée
pouvez-nous nous indiquer quelles sont
les actions interministérielles je
suppose conduite par le gouvernement en
matière de lutte contre le séparatisme
mais surtout pour l'appropriation et le
partage des valeurs de la république
merci monsieur débuté la parole et à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs et député monsieur le
député pour lien vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la république la semaine
dernière a présenté un plan d'action
global un plan d'action de gueule parce
qu'effectivement lutter contre le
séparatisme islamistes en particulier
dans certaines de nos quartiers implique
d' agir sur tous les fronts d'abord
celui dans l'esprit de ce que nous avons
initié dès février 2018 qui consiste à
s'opposer à toute dérive par rapport au
respect des lois de la république et
faire en sorte que les préfets puissent
conduire la reconquête républicaine
mètre carré par mètre carré par tous
elle a reculé sa stratégie
entraves à porter ses fruits dans ses 15
quartiers denses et 15 quartiers nous
avons ainsi fermé quinze lieux de culte
nous ont fermé 12 établissements cultuel
et culturel quatre écoles mais aussi 150
débits de boisson et redresser près de
19 millions d'euros de cotisations
notamment de cotisations sociales parce
que une chose est sûre c'est que ce
séparatisme s'organise comme un
écosystème global contre lequel il nous
faut lutter mais vous l'avez évoqué il
nous faut construire une stratégie
globale
une stratégie qui effectivement s'appuie
sur le pied répressif chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire mais aussi sur la
reconquête républicaine et la robe
conquête républicaine doit être mené à
plusieurs niveaux un des champs que le
président la république a évoqué la
semaine dernière celui de l'indépendance
face aux influences étrangères et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il a annoncé la
suppression d enseignement en langue et
culture étrangère à partir du mois de
septembre
c'est la raison pour laquelle il a
souhaité que nous engagions très
rapidement un plan pour mettre un terme
à cette pratique de mise à disposition
d'imams détaché par des pays étrangers
mais il nous faut travailler aussi sur
la question du financement non pas pour
punir un culte comme certains le
proposent aujourd'hui mais pour faire en
sorte que le financement se fasse dans
la transparence et dans le contrôle
enfin vous avez raison il est
indispensable que nous agissions au plus
près du terrain à la fois avec les
collectivités locales à la fois avec les
associations et c'est le sens de la
réunion qui est organisée cet après midi
par le président de la république merci
monsieur le ministre la parole devant la
marine bonnier des pieds de cette
journée la chine d'abord est désormais
le reste du monde connaisse une équipe
chère collègue chers collègues
excusez moi je n'ai pas laisser monsieur
poulet a exprimé sa réplique je vous
rendrai la parole pardonnez moi je merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre je voulais effectivement
assisté sur le point que ils étaient les
tours jean de rétablir la promesse
républicaine sur l'ensemble des
territoires et pour tous nos concitoyens
bien la parole est donc à madame marine
brenier et elle seule merci monsieur le
président avec les ministres depuis le 7
janvier la chine d'abord est désormais
le reste du monde connaît une épidémie
extrêmement virulente du coronavirus le
26 janvier dernier le maire de nice
christian estrosi a écrit à la ministre
de la santé en demandant la mise en
place d'un comité d'experts composé de
médecins infectiologues et pharmaciens
pour proposer des actions rapides et
concrètes afin d'être prêts dans les
meilleurs délais lors d'une réunion
organisée hier à la préfecture des
alpes-maritimes
le maire de nice en tant que président
du conseil de surveillance du chu a
demandé des moyens humains et matériels
supplémentaires pour détecter le virus
et garantir la prise en charge des
patients
nous tenons d'ailleurs à nos tours a
salué l'engagement de tous les
professionnels de santé mobilisés à nice
ils ont collaboré avec les universités
chinoises sur la progression de
l'épidémie
la situation est préoccupante et exige
de la part de tous une coopération
responsable le temps de l'incubation du
virus étant de 14 jours et les patients
sains difficilement détectables comme
tchernobyl le virus risque de ne pas
s'arrêter à nos frontières
voilà pourquoi nous demandons la
garantie qu'au niveau du chu de nice
comme dans les établissements sanitaires
les moyens nécessaires à la détection et
la prise en charge des patients soient
mobilisés sans perdre une seconde que
tous les praticiens de santé médicaux et
paramédicaux constituent des éléments de
relais de vigilance pour faire face à
toutes les inquiétudes est que les
collectivités soit informé et qu'enfin
en association avec les ars
les services de l'état les collectivités
territoriales l'industrie pharmaceutique
soit mobilisée pour empêcher la pénurie
des masques et de certains médicaments
monsieur le premier ministre il est
essentiel que les pouvoirs publics
puissent garantir à nos concitoyens que
nous sommes prêts à affronter l'épidémie
la france a su démontré par le passé
qu'elle pouvait s'organiser face à de
tels risques
nos collectivités seront mobilisés en
responsabilité
aux côtés de l'état merci de nous
communiquer votre plan d'action pour
assurer la santé des français
je vends merci merci il avait débuté la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée vous m'interrogez à la suite
d'autres questions sur les mesures
prises à la fois par le gouvernement par
l'état et par l'ensemble des services de
santé pour préparer la france à
l'hypothèse de plus en plus probable
d'une transmission et d'une diffusion du
coronavirus sur le territoire national
vous aurez remarqué c'est bien évident
que nous prenons ce sujet très au
sérieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès qu'il
est apparu en chine en bonne
intelligence avec les autorités
chinoises nous avons veillé à rapatrier
en france le plus rapidement possible
tous les ressortissants français
amour un amour ou orales pardon de façon
à ce qu'ils puissent être placés en
france dans des situations quarantaine
est ce que nous puissions veiller sur
l'évolution de leur santé ces opérations
se sont bien déroulées elles se sont
bien déroulées grâce au très grand
engagement des services de l'étape se
sont bien déroulées aussi grâce à
l'accueil remarquable et à la gestion
remarquable des élus locaux dans les
endroits où nous avons choisi de placer
ces françaises et français
nous avons ensuite pris un certain
nombre de mesures pour préparer notre
système de soins mis en alerte les chu
qui sont les mieux armés pour accueillir
le cas échéant les personnes qui
seraient en situation d'être affectés
veiller à ce que dans tous les
départements
un hôpital celui qui héberge les
services du samu soit en mesure
d'accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
ceux des éventuels malades qui
développeraient des complications qui
imposerait leur hospitalisation
nous avons veillé à passer les commandes
nécessaires pour que les matériels
utiles aux soignants puisse être
disponible
nous avons veillé à faire monter en
production à la fois pardon
nous avons veillé à ce que les instituts
de recherche qu'il faut je dois le dire
à la fois l'honneur la fierté d'une
certaine façon oui la très grande fierté
de nos concitoyens soient les premiers à
identifier les caractéristiques de ce
virus ça a été le cas et nous veillons à
ce que la capacité de notre système à
produire des tests et à les utiliser
soit à la hauteur des enjeux
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours 400 tests
pouvaient être produit analysé à
l'hôpital de marseille
nous sommes passés nous avons réussi à
faire passer la capacité de production
et l'analyse de ces textes de ces tests
à 1000 tests par jour c'est évidemment
décisif pour pouvoir identifier les
règles et cas réels des fausses alertes
et il ne vous a pas échappé que toutes
les alertes qui ont été signalés sur le
territoire national depuis quelques
jours était en réalité et c'est tant
mieux
des fausses alertes mais il faut pouvoir
les tester pour pouvoir dire que c'est
une fausse olé alors évidemment je
comprends l'inquiétude et le
questionnement posée par ceux des
territoires qui se trouve le plus proche
de la frontière italienne
bien entendu les décisions prises par
les autorités italiennes ont pu conduire
un certain nombre de responsables
français à se demander s'il ne fallait
pas en miroir prendre les mêmes
décisions par exemple interrompre avant
son terme
le carnaval de nice comme cela avait été
décidé à venise j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir dès dimanche soir avec le
maire de nice car bien entendu nous
veillons à ce que les décisions qui sont
prises
les analyses qui sont proposés puisse
l'être fait en bonne intelligence avec
les élus locaux qui ont localement à
répondre aux questionnements voir à
prendre des décisions
ce contact a eu lieu dimanche soir avec
le maire de nice et nous sommes convenus
d'appliquer ce qui est la doctrine
française en matière de gestion des
épidémies ou des risques d'épidémies
tant que le foyer temps pardon que le
virus ne circule pas sur le territoire
national il n'est pas utile de prendre
ces mesures de prévention ce qu'il
convient en revanche de faire c'est de
faire en sorte que notre système soit
prêt c'est ce que nous faisons
j'ai envoyé je les dis tout
alors un courrier à l'ensemble des
maires et l'ensemble des exécutifs
locaux nous faisons monter en pression
le système de santé pour qu'il soit
opérationnel le moment venu et j'aurai
l'occasion avec l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe et des présidents
de partis politiques d'évoquer l'état de
du risque sur le territoire national et
la réponse que nous sommes en mesure de
faire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est un monsieur daniel laval
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre jeudi
dernier dans les vosges monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez présidé le
premier comité interministériel sur les
ruralité ce comité intervient un an
après un accord qui a été passé entre
vous même et vanik berberian le
président de l'association des maires
ruraux de france
cet accord portait sur l'élaboration
d'un agenda rural c'est à dire un plan
national en faveur des territoires
ruraux
vous avez installé une mission agenda
rural qui a proposé 200 propositions qui
a fait 200 propositions et à l'occasion
de l'association des maires ruraux du
congrès de l'association des maires
ruraux
vous avez décidé de retenir 173 de ses
200 propositions et vous avez pris un
engagement celui de tenir un comité
interministériel six mois après ce
congrès de septembre
engagement tenu ce comité
interministériel fait suite à des
comités de suivi de mise en oeuvre des
propositions de l'agenda rural sous
l'autorité de madame jacqueline gourault
milices dans la cohésion des territoires
je veux ici souligner à la fois la
rapidité de la mise en oeuvre des
propositions de l'agenda rural mais
aussi le fait que ces propositions
doivent s'inscrire dans la durée parce
que si nous avons une politique de la
ville depuis une quarantaine d'années
nous n'avions pas une politique peut
établir en faveur de la ruralité et le
gouvernement s'est engagé à mettre en
oeuvre cette politique en faveur des
rues réalité sur le long terme
ce comité interministériel dans le cadre
de ce comité interministériel vous avez
fait un certain nombre de propositions
s'agissant des petites lignes
ferroviaires s'agissant également de du
déploiement du numérique dans les
territoires ruraux
monsieur le premier ministre mais
question sont donc que simple pouvez
vous nous rappeler dans quel état dans
quel contexte
cet agenda rural a été
c'est qu'est ce que vous en attendez
s'agissant de la revitalisation de nos
territoires ruraux je vous remercie
la parole à madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion de territoire et
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
le député merci beaucoup pour votre
question l'agenda rural je le rappelle a
été annoncée par le premier ministre le
20 septembre dernier à l'occasion du
congrès de l'association des maires
ruraux de france qui avait lieu à
eppe-sauvage dans le département du nord
c'est sur une idée au fonds proposés par
le parlement européen c'est à dire un
agenda rural européen que le
gouvernement français a été le premier à
suivre
cette initiative soutenue vous l'avez
dit par vanik berberian le président des
maires ruraux de france et pour
construire cet agenda
le premier ministre a confié une mission
composée d'élus ruraux pour réfléchir à
ce sujet et vous avez remis puisque vous
faisiez partie de cette délégation de
cette mission monsieur le député vous
m'avez remis un rapport fin juillet qui
s'appelait ruralité une ambition à
partager je crois qu'il faut la chose
sur laquelle il faut insister c'est que
cet agenda rural et le premier plan
d'action d'un gouvernement en faveur des
ruralités qui regroupe des enjeux aussi
large que ce soit la transition
écologique l'agriculture l'éducation la
santé la formation l'emploi les
mobilités la culture le développement
économique c'est une vision globale de
la ruralité et pour assurer son
exécution le gouvernement a imaginé
effectivement des comités
interministériels réguliers aux réalités
vous avez rappelé le premier qui s'est
tenue dans les vosges sous l'autorité du
premier ministre et les comités de suivi
très régulier ou participent beaucoup de
mini
str le dernier a eu lieu en novembre
beaucoup de choses ont été faites depuis
cette décision
je rappelle quelques points qui sont
importants le soutien aux petits
commerces
le prolongement des zones de
revitalisation rurale jusqu'à fin 2020
pour les 4000 comme une heure ci devait
sortir est bien là mais devant les
murailles
la parole est à monsieur sébastien jumel
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
déclaré le 11 décembre dernier au cee
avec le nouveau système nous réglons les
problèmes des petites retraites
notamment celles des agriculteurs
dans le même temps emmanuel macron en
février 2018 au salon de l'agriculture
disait je ne peux pas avoir d'un côté
des agriculteurs qui n'ont pas de
retraite et de l'autre un statut de
cheminot et ne pas le changer je veux
vous rafraîchir la mémoire temps vous
avez usé de cet important sujet d'une
retraite agricole digne qui fait
consensus comme d'un argument de foire
pour mieux vendre votre réforme de
retraites rejeté par les français
cette même ficelle abalo a été utilisé
pour bloquer l'adoption de la
proposition de loi chassaigne en 2018 au
sénat trop tôt revenez dont la troisième
semaine
lors de l'examen de notre formidable
réforme en préparation on voit le
résultat
la parole donnée est trahi ou et tout ce
qu'on se tape disait macron au dernier
salon de l'agriculture
vous tentez de vendre une carne pour un
bon cheval
les mauves et maquignons que vous êtes
sont démasqués non seulement les anciens
exploitants qui vivent sous le seuil de
la pauvreté non bénéficieront pas mais
en plus votre promesse à 1000 euros pour
les futurs retraités ne prendra pas en
compte les carrières qui ne sont pas
complètes sans les définir et laisseront
aux autres la bsaa vous aviez attelé la
charrue de la réforme des retraites
derrière des agriculteurs et il récolte
aujourd'hui une moisson de larmes au
moment même
au moment même où vous offrait 4
milliards d'euros aux plus hauts revenus
monsieur le premier ministre croyez nous
nous reviendrons à la charge lors de
l'examen en seconde lecture de la
proposition doit chassaigne car pour
nous les promesses faites doivent être
des promesses tenues
merci monsieur le député comme quand
vous dites macron vous pourriez dire le
président de la république ça ne gâte
rien la parole est à monsieur laurent
pietrasinski secrétaire d'état chargé
des retraites
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs et député monsieur le député
sébastien jumel
nous avons à plusieurs reprises déjà
débattu de cela dans nos travaux de la
commission spéciale et dans l'hémicycle
ici sur le projet de loi retraites
vous le savez l'engagement du président
de la république et du gouvernement est
totale en matière de petites retraites
nous avons un engagement qui sera tenu
car dès 2022 et encore plus pour les
retraités agricoles puisque dès 2022 ils
seront à 85% du smic
donc la réalité la réalité des
engagements du gouvernement ce sont les
engagements qui seront tenus et qui
s'adresse vous avez raison le souligner
tout particulièrement à ceux qui ont des
petites retraites et notamment les
retraités agricoles qui très souvent
très souvent cotis sur une base de 800
heures smic l'équivalent de 800 heures
smic par an et qui à ce titre là arrive
à avoir des durées relativement
significative en matière de cotisations
et demain et demain vous le savez
monsieur le député sébastien jumel car
nous l'avons déjà dit non seulement nous
baisserons le montant des cotisations
des exploitants agricoles qui passeront
sur les cotisations minimales as
l'équivalent de 600 heures smic
mais comme les autres exploitants comme
les autres professions libérales et
indépendant ils bénéficieront de la
révision de l'assiette de cg ce qui
devrait le ramener une baisse de pour
plus de 40% des agriculteurs de leur
niveau de charge
la réalité monsieur jumelles c'est que
l'ensemble des agriculteurs qui
prendront leur retraite dès 2022 se
retrouveront dans une situation bien
meilleure que celle qui n'a jamais été
apportée par aucune majorité ici depuis
plus de 30 ans la réalité c'est que le
gouvernement oui le gouvernement ce
gouvernement travaille parce que la vie
la vie des retraités de plus modestes et
notamment des retraités agricoles
demain soit plus belle que la même ici
dans le chacun chez soi
merci monsieur mus la parole est à
monsieur patrick loiseau ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre elisabeth
bornes dans la nuit du 27 au 28 février
2010 un événement climatique d'une
extrême violence a touché la france et
le littoral atlantique
la conjonction de la tempête xynthia et
de fortes marées occasionné une
subversion marine sans précédent et
d'importantes inondations jojo
aujourd'hui une pensée pour les quarante
sept personnes décédées dont 29 pour la
seule commune de la faute-sur-mer sur
moi dans ma circonscription de vendée
c'était il ya tout juste dix ans nous
commémorons ce tragique événement
dimanche prochain et je vous remercie
madame la ministre de votre
participation à cet hommage
depuis une réelle prise de conscience
collective a eu lieu de l'urbanisation
trans fière de notre littoral
parfois au mépris des règles existantes
de la vétusté et de la fragilité des
ouvrages de protection une prise de
conscience surtout de notre
vulnérabilité face à l'urgence
climatique car partout dans le monde ces
phénomènes sont amenés à s'intensifier à
sera prêt se rapprocher le dernier
rapport du giec sur les océans à la
cryosphère démontre que le niveau de la
mer risque de s'accroître d'un mètre par
endroits sur le littoral atlantique à
l'horizon 2100 il ya quelques semaines
l'agencé européenne de l'environnement
est venue confirmer ce constat alarmant
à la suite de la tempête xynthia
nombreuses ont été les initiatives pour
anticiper et gérer ce type d'événement
un plan de rénovation des digues des
programmes d'action de prévention des
inondations
et divers plans d'action ont notamment
été mises en oeuvre pourtant force est
de constater que les acteurs locaux se
heurte parfois à une forte complexité
administrative
cependant l'urgence est réelle et nous
devons redoubler d'efforts pour garantir
la sécurité de tous et tous face à la
montée des eaux et aux catastrophes
naturelles dues aux raids dérèglement
climatique
aussi madame la ministre que proposez
vous pour une prévention et gestion des
risques optimale en vue de garantir la
sécurité des populations vivant sur le
littoral
je remercie mr si chacun un rapport
notamment dame elizabeth bord le nist de
la transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
patrick loiseau je serai dimanche dans
les territoires touchés par la tempête
xynthia en vendée et en
charente-maritime pour commémorer les
dix ans de cet événement dramatique
personne n'a oublié la violence de cet
épisode qui comme vous l'avez rappelé a
conduit à une perte de 47 vie
cette tempête a contribué à une prise de
conscience de notre vulnérabilité face à
ces phénomènes de submersion marine qui
sont en effet appelé à s'amplifier
du fait du dérèglement climatique et
aujourd'hui en france ce sont 17
millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
concernées par ce risque submersion et
inondations alors dès 2011 le plan
submersions marines avaient conduit à
apporter des outils dans les territoires
concernés
mais le 12 février dernier nous avons
franchi une nouvelle étape
le conseil de défense écologique a acté
et des avancées dans deux domaines tout
d'abord une accélération des procédures
et une garantie financière pour faire
face à ce risque submersion et
inondations en particulier les délais
pour élaborer les plans d'action pour la
prévention des inondations devons être
divisé par deux grâce à une
déconcentration de l'essentiel des
procédures et puis également dans le
même temps nous allons créer des
nouveaux outils pour permettre aux
territoire de faire face aux risques de
retrait du littoral notamment avec la
mise en place d'un nouveau permis de
construire pour des occupations
temporaires dans les territoires menacé
à moyen terme donc vous voyez nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés pour
accompagner les territoires et apporter
des solutions construites au plus près
avec les élus car si vous n'avez la
ministre la parole est un monsieur
maxime minots merci monsieur le
président monsieur comme ministre
si cela continue il va y avoir un drame
maxime j'ai la boule au ventre
à chaque fois que je monte dans mon
tracteur que répondent à christophe cet
agriculteur de ma circonscription
victime une nouvelle fois de menaces
alors qu'il travaillait dans son champ
bien sûr que je le soutiens
bien sûr qu'il ne doit pas céder au
désespoir pourtant comment l'en
dissuader alors que ce gouvernement et
cette majorité le méprisent
oui vous le mépriser quand vous mettez
pas tout en oeuvre pour consolider la
pac
oui vous le mépriser quand vous faites
voter des lois aux espoirs déçus qui
n'améliore rien sur votre conscience et
plombe la production
oui vous le mépriser quand jupiter
descendant au salon de l'agriculture
l'ordi droit dans les yeux que rien
n'est possible pour leur retraite
et pourtant qui est il lui parmi tant
d'autres un agriculteur qui travaillent
du lever au coucher du soleil
une terre qu'il a su respecter
apprivoiser avec un niveau d'exigence
inégal bien loin des sachants boboïsée
un agriculteur qui ne demandent rien
d'autre que de vivre décemment de son
travail et transmettre sa passion à la
génération suivante
un agriculteur respectueux de la loi et
de toutes autres contraintes
administratives
là où tant d'autres y compris ceux qui
l'accusent trop souvent les bafouent il
est le passé issus d'un savoir faire
mondialement reconnu et gardiens de
notre identité rurale
il est le présent capable d'évoluer pour
se confronter aux défis de demain à
condition de ne pas exiger plus de lui
que nous le faisons nous mêmes
il est le futur car sans lui qui nous
nourrira demain en nous évitant le tout
ogm ou des produits d'une qualité
médiocre
donc personne ne veut la france restera
telle la france sans ses agriculteurs
monsieur le premier ministre nous
connaissons tous la réponse à cette
question alors battez vous pour eux
pour nous et quand allez vous entendre
enfin nos propositions pour le monde
agricole
la parole est un monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés merci monsieur le
député minots de votre question alors il
ya un certain nombre de hal et
reconnaissons le de caricatures dans les
éléments que vous donner mais je crois
que nous partageons et nous pouvons
partager sur ses bancs la volonté de
défendre l'agriculture et la volonté de
défendre des agriculteurs qu'ils soient
présents sur l'ensemble du territoire
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
défendre parce que il ya les mots vous
prononcez il ya les actes qu'on effectue
ya la loi et galim attendait monsieur
minots si je peux pas répondre à la
question êtes-vous fait de l'obstruction
aux questions au gouvernement c'est un
problème monsieur minot monsieur minot
ya la question du revenu des
agriculteurs vous avez raison de l'avoir
levé la question du revenu des
agriculteurs c'était l'objectif et c'est
l'objectif des états généraux de
l'alimentation en particulier dans son
titre l'un comme l'a rappelé madame
panière une hache et à l'instant non
monsieur benoit d'ailleurs fort
justement je crois à la dia l'instant il
ya des éléments qui sont positifs et qui
vont dans le bon sens c'est d'ailleurs
reconnu par la profession agricole
il ya des éléments sur lequel il faut
évoluer le président de la république le
gouvernement le ministre de
l'agriculture ont dit qu'ils auraient un
certain nombre d'évolutions
si les résultats n'étaient pas au rendez
vous de la loi telle qu'elle était
attendue parce que il y aura pas
d'agriculture et d'agriculteurs sans
revenu monsieur minots la deuxième chose
je voudrais corriger les choses parce
que vous avez du mal sur ce qui s'est
passé au parc au niveau de l'union
européenne ce week-end pourquoi il ya eu
un échec sur le budget européen ce
week-end c'est parce que le président de
la république s'est opposé au budget tel
qu'il était présenté et qui visait et
qui visait à sacrifier l'agriculture sur
l'autel du budget européen
non simplement simplement le budget
nécessite unanimité le président de la
république a dit que dans des conditions
telles qu'il était présenté
nous n'accepterions pas un budget qui
viendraient sacrifier l'agriculture et
puis la troisième chose monsieur minots
et nous partageons je crois est vraiment
je crois que nous partageons nous avons
besoin de redonner confiance aux
agriculteurs et nous avons besoin
collectivement de redonner confiance aux
agriculteurs et je pense que c'est
collectivement que nous en ce n'est pas
qu'une question du gouvernement et de
l'est d'une majorité c'est la question
du gouvernement d'une majorité d'une
opposition pour leur redonner confiance
sur le revenu et c'est la politique
agricole que nous mènerons dans les
années qui viennent
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
d'un monsieur jean michel clément
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre il ya
bientôt trois ans un enfant de 5 ans
scolarisé dans une école maternelle de
la vienne décédé d'une tuberculose
transmise par une enseignante
remplaçante ayant exercé dans plusieurs
écoles un an après cette tragédie ni les
craintes d'une contagion existait
toujours
chers collègues il y a une population où
le taux de cas de tuberculose est dix
fois plus élevé que dans le reste de la
population
c'est celle des sans abri parmi eux
figurent des demandeurs d'asile qui sont
d'autant plus éloignée du parcours de
soins qu'un décret publié le 30 décembre
dernier
instituer un délai de carence de 90
jours pour accéder aux soins auxquels
s'ajoute le délai d'instruction des
dossiers
ce décret qui expose notre pays est un
problème de santé publique majeur est un
recul sans précédent dans la prise en
charge médicale des personnes
particulièrement exposées à de graves
problèmes de santé en raison de
mauvaises conditions d'hygiène et de
soins à l'heure où la propagation du
corona virus s'accentue cette décision
participe d'un déni de réalité qu'il
faut reconsidérer aussi au nom de la
protection de la santé publique et du
principe d'humanité
le groupe liberty les territoires
souhaite savoir si vous allez abroger ce
décret instituant un délai de carence de
90 jours pour ces personnes fragilisées
accédants pour accuser qu'ils puissent
accéder aux soins pardon nous adonnons
aussi comme notre mon collègue michel
castellani vous l'a demandé
il a demandé à monsieur mise de la santé
il ya deux jours des mesures pour
contrôler l'état sanitaire des personnes
qui débarquent en corse en provenance de
pays exposés au virus comme l'italie
enfin de nombreux pays africains ne
pourront pas faire face aux kora le
virus l'inquiétude est grande chez nos
ressortissants et tous les expatriés
quelles réponses allez vous leur
apportez ainsi qu'aux états africains
dont le savons les équipements de soins
insuffisant et qui ne manqueront pas
d'en appeler à notre aide jour merci
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur adrien taquet secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député merci tout d'abord
pour la question que vous posez qui
pointe les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer un certain nombre de
populations sensibles sur notre
territoire ou à l'étranger
deux éléments de réponse redire tout de
même qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
circulation de virus sur notre
territoire
il est important de le rappeler et de
rappeler que notre stratégie est
fonction du niveau de risque et qu'elle
sera adaptable révisable à tout moment
en fonction notamment pas exclusivement
des populations qui peuvent être
particulièrement exposés vous le savez
il y a hier une circulaire a été envoyée
à l'ensemble des établissements
scolaires
cet après midi par l'intermédiaire du
courrier envoyé par le premier ministre
à l'ensemble des maires et des
départements à l'ensemble des
établissements qui peuvent être sous
leur tutelle leurs responsabilités je
pense en particulier au conservatoire de
musique qui peuvent être la
responsabilité des des municipalités
pour mettre en place l'ensemble des
dispositions nécessaires pour les
personnes qui reviendrait des zones à
risque aujourd'hui dans le monde qu'il
s'agisse de la chine où ou du nord de
l'italie
tout est fait aujourd'hui pour en france
je le redis freiner l'introduction dû
virus sur notre territoire par le
dépistage des cas possibles je les dis
nous avons augmenté
nous avons augmenté nos capacités de
diagnostic par l' isolement des malades
ou encore par l'ensemble des procédures
qui ont pu être mises en place comme à
la contamines-montjoie la semaine
dernière une fois encore si demain si
demain le virus devaient circuler en
france nous adapterons l'ensemble des
procédures et des recommandations à nos
concitoyens ce n'est pas parce que nous
n'avons pas par exemple annulé
aujourd'hui d'événements sportifs ça
fait l'objet d'un certain non
de de questionnements là par nos
concitoyens que nous ne le ferons pas
demain en fonction de l'évolution
silencieuse une histoire la parole est à
monsieur dominique potier merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre le salon de
l'agriculture cette année c'est une
alerte et un appel et sur l' alerte d 1
million 3 d'agriculteurs de paysans qui
pour ceux qui n'ont pas de patrimoine du
moins vivent une retraite dans la
dignité
les réponses que nous avons entendu une
sont pas satisfaisantes elles ne peuvent
pas être satisfaisant pourrait rappeler
simplement pour la vérité des faits que
le groupe communiste groupe socialiste
c'est la proposition perros la
proposition chassaigne ont proposé des
processus législatif
nous proposons dans nos amendements des
solutions de financement j'en donnerai
simplement 2009
yahia il ya tout un panel de
propositions et la une qui vise
simplement à augmenter la cotisation de
ce que vous exonérer aujourd'hui de
cotisation en augmentant leur part de
solidarité il ya là des marges de
manoeuvre importantes
l'autre qui représenterait 3 % de ce qui
est attendu pour la dignité des
retraites agricoles
c'est simplement tout simplement une
taxation des revenus du capital
3 % de cette taxation suffirait à
satisfaire le besoin la dignité des
paysans à eux réclament l'objet redire
ce point là et il n'est pas possible
dans l'état de fracturation de notre
société où nous sommes que le parlement
ces propositions réunies surtout les
rangs sur cette question là fassent
l'objet d'une fin de non recevoir car il
y aurait un diktat du président de la
république
maintenant je devrais dire je vais
repasser de la leyre à l'appel l'appel
c'est le fait tout simplement que nous
avons aujourd'hui un tiers des
agriculteurs qui vont partir en retraite
qui ont cessé leur activité dans les
cinq ans la moitié dans les dix ans
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas de relève
si la libéralisation du marché foncier
se poursuit c'est une destruction des
emplois c'est une destruction de la
valeur économique
c'est une destruction de la valeur
écologique tels que le giec l'a défini
sur le sol il ne faut garantir cette
relève elle passe par une régulation des
marchés à l'échelle nationale européenne
et internationale
elle passe par un partage du foncier
nous étions dix huit organisations ce
matin 18 organisations
les cinq syndicats agricoles neuf
organisations non gouvernementales trois
organisations de territoire il y avait
jean michel clément jean bernard
sempastous surtout les rangs nous vous
garantissons deux tiers à 80% du
parlement derrière vous il faut faire
cette loi foncière sans justice fonds
sert pas de relève et pas d'un gros
écologique
merci monsieur le député la réponse à
partir monsieur marc fesneau ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
potier vous me permettrait de répondre
sur la deuxième partie de la question si
j'ai bien compris le sens de la question
que vous les posez sur la question
foncière
comme vous le savez je voudrais saluer
le travail que vous faites avec un
certain nombre de vos collègues et c'est
pas simplement pour vous faire plaisir
c'est parce que c'est la vérité sur ce
sujet là qui vous préoccupent et qui
nous préoccupe aussi reconnaissons
d'abord que ce qu'on appelle
l'accaparement des terres ou la question
foncière n'est pas une question tout à
fait nouvelle c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il ya 50 ou 60 ans nous aînés avaient
décidé de se doter d'outils qui
permettait de réguler quelle est la
nouveauté au fond
l'agrandissement des exploitations n'est
pas tout à fait nouveau la mécanisation
la productivité ont fait que deux au fur
et à mesure les exploitations se sont à
demander quel est le fait nouveau que
vous soulevez que vous avez raison de
soulever c'est que l'organisation des
exploitations parfois le dévoiement on
va dire des lois telles qu'elles avaient
été prévues font qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'exploitations s'agrandissent
dans des proportions qui sont démesurées
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments qui
sont sur la table aurait rappelé que le
ministre de l'agriculture a décidé de
lancer un certain nombre de groupes de
travail auxquels vous participez sur un
certain nombre de sujets que vous levez
auquel vous pouvez contribuer puisqu'il
ya des contributions sur lequel vous
contribuez qui permettront de travailler
à la fois là sur les questions de face
ce type de zone de fiscalité les
questions de transmissibilité d
exploitation les questions d'outils de
régulation qu'ils soient plus haut en
adéquation avec les sujets et les
sociétés qui sont en train de se créer
qui peuvent essayer de dévoyer les
choses le troisième sujet je voudrais
évoquer avec vous c'est que je pense que
la question foncière est une question
centrale mais ce n'est pas la seule
question pour installer des agriculteurs
je peux vous le savez la question pour
installer des agriculteurs c'est de leur
garantir du revenu et c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse reprendre d
exploitation dans des conditions qui
soient économiquement viable la deuxième
question qu'il faut qu'on se pose aussi
c'est la transmissibilité d exploitation
et ce n'est pas qu'une question foncière
il ya des outils de production qui ne
sont pas capables et c'est là qu'on aura
besoin sans doute d'éléments et de
sociétés de portage qui permettront de
le faire il me semble que c'est sa fille
le 2 la troisième chose que je crois est
que nous croyons c'est qu'on a besoin
d'avoir une politique commune agricole
commune et une politique accompagnant
les transitions nécessaires de
l'agriculture qui soit claire pour les
agriculteurs on a besoin d'avoir des
éléments de moyen et long termes sur les
transition écologique sur l'éclosion
agro écologiques et c'est bien ça qu'on
a devant nous à la fois sur les
questions foncières et plus globalement
pour leur redonner confiance
merci monsieur nice la parole est à
madame lauriane en russie merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
monsieur le ministre mardi dernier
maître frédéric thiriez remettait au
premier ministre les conclusions de la
mission que lui avait confiée le
président de la république en vue de
refonder le recrutement la formation et
la gestion des carrières de nos hauts
fonctionnaires lors de sa conférence de
presse du 25 avril 2019 le chef de
l'état avait manifesté sa volonté
d'ouvrir l'accès à la haute fonction
publique
encore trop peu représentatif de notre
société et d'en transformer la gestion
tant humaines que statutaire la crise
des gilet jaune a également exprimé la
volonté de nos concitoyens d'en finir
avec des situations qui s'apparente
parfois à des rentes le rapport tire
yeahs comprend trois titres décloisonner
diversifié dynamiser décloisonner
d'abord en créant une formation initiale
pour tous les futurs cadres supérieurs
de notre haute fonction publique des
sept grandes écoles du service public ce
tronc commun comprendra trois semaines
de préparation militaire trois semaines
consacré à l'encadrement des jeunes du
service national universel et 4 mois de
stage opérationnel sur le terrain
diversifié ensuite en créant de
nouvelles modalités de recrutement dans
les grandes écoles s'en remettre
évidemment en cause le principe du
concours seule garantie de l'égalité
d'accès aux emplois publics proclamée
par l'article 6 de la déclaration des
droits de 1789
nous savons en effet que le recrutement
de nos hauts fonctionnaires demeure
hélas excessivement concentré parmi les
enfants de familles de professions
intellectuelles supérieures et qu'il
nous appartient de lutter contre ces
mécanismes de reproduction sociale
dynamiser enfin car pour citer le
rapport depuis trop longtemps l'état
s'intéresse davantage au statu quo
personne elle-même la direction générale
de l'administration de la fonction
publique sera ainsi renforcée monsieur
le ministre vous nous préciser le
calendrier du gouvernement pour mettre
en oeuvre ces préconisations et nous
préciser quelles sont celles qui vous
paraissent prioritaires
je vous remercie merci veulent débuter
la parole est à monsieur olivier du soap
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
merci à monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée rossi vous l'avez dit monsieur
thiriez a remis son rapport avec 42
propositions au chef du gouvernement qui
m'a chargé d'instruire ses propositions
en lien avec les différents membres du
gouvernement ou dans trois priorités la
première des priorités est de
diversifier et d'améliorer la carrière
des hauts fonctionnaires
nous voulons à la fois que celles et
ceux qui se destinent après l'école de
la haute fonction publique à des
missions d'inspection juridiction puisse
acquérir au préalable une expérience en
administration actives dans des missions
prioritaires
nous voulons aussi permettre à celles et
ceux qui n'auraient pas accès aux grands
corps après leur scolarité dans les
écoles de service public d'avoir une
autre chance dans leur carrière d'y
accéder à un site participer à une
meilleure diversification de l'accès à
ces fonctions de haute direction
nous voulons aussi faire en sorte vous
l'avez dit qu'il y ait un tronc commun
et que l'ensemble des hauts
fonctionnaires puissent acquérir les
mêmes enseignements avoir en partage les
mêmes valeurs de l'état que ce tronc
commun puisse aussi comporter des
périodes de stage les périodes de
valorisation de l'engagement citoyen
soit au travers de l'encadrement du et
ses nus c'est une des propositions ou
par d'autres moyens nous nous appuierons
sur les propositions du rapport frédéric
thiriez enfin nous voulons surtout
peut-être diversifier l'accès à la haute
fonction publique diversifie laxalt
fonction publique c'est réfléchir aux
modalités de concours
peut-être pour qu'ils soient moins
académique - universitaire qu'il
favorise la prise en compte des
capacités des potentiels de leadership
le savoir être et la volonté de mener à
bien sa carrière
c'est tard en sorte aussi d'avoir plus
d'égalité dans les chances d'accès à
l'école aux écoles de la haute fonction
publique
nous voulons rapidement mettre en place
plus de classe préparatoire égalité des
chances avec des systèmes de bourses et
d'accompagnement pour permettre à des
jeunes issus de familles ou de
territoires défavorisés d'être mieux
accompagnée mieux préparés et casser les
déterminismes sociaux qui vous l'avez
dit sont encore extrêmement présent nous
voulons faire cela dès le mois d'avril
et je proposerai des dispositions ce
sens au premier ministre en lien
évidemment avec le ministre de
l'éducation et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur toutes les
dispositions nécessaires à l'affreux
tronc commun à la diversification du
recrutement à une meilleure gestion des
carrières trouveront leur place dans une
ordonnance permise par la loi du 6
juillet 2010 9 qui sera présenté avant
la fin du second trimestre
la parole est un monsieur loïc
prud'hommes
merci monsieur le président le seul
premier ministre
j'étais hier au salon de l'agriculture
alors que résonnaient encore dans les
allées les renoncements du président de
la république
de son propre aveu il ne mettra pas un
centime de plus pour les agriculteurs
déjà retraités
pire encore je tiens à dénoncer votre
fausse promesse de niveau de retraite
agricole à 1000 euros en 2022 il
faudrait pour les seuls chefs
d'exploitation accumulé 50 heures par
mois au smic pendant 500 16 mois sans
interruption
autant dire une chimère qui n'existera
pas un enfumage de plus voilà déjà pour
le présent et l'avenir n'est pas plus
rassurant le président macron mise sur
les discussions actuelles autour du
budget européen de la pac pour faire
mine de s'intéresser à l'avenir et aux
revenus de la profession alors qu'il
n'en est rien la pac
ce n'est pas qu'un tiroir caisse c'est
avant tout une politique
mais quelle politique c'est la question
que se posent les agriculteurs
relocaliser les productions produire
sainement garantir des prix planchers un
revenu paysan sortir des pesticides
créer de l'emploi
il est urgent d'opérer une refonte de
notre modèle agricole pour qu'il réponde
aux urgences climatiques et
environnementales pour qu'il permette à
nos producteurs de vivre décemment pour
les affranchir de leurs dépendants de
leur dépendance aux firmes agrochimiques
vos numéros numéro de communication
comme celui autour d'un aghrib aching
fantasmer ne suffiront pas à faire
croire que votre volonté est de protéger
l'agriculture française et ses paysans
alors que les accords de libre échange
sont signés à tour de bras
tel le funeste c'est à avec le canada la
question que nous devons nous poser
collectivement et quel contrat social la
nation veut-elle signé avec ses
agriculteurs
pour cela il n'est pas pensable que le
plan stratégique national qui dessine la
pac et cet avenir soit discutée
seulement dans les couloirs du ministère
monsieur le premier ministre je vous le
demande solennellement quand allez vous
ouvrir le débat parlementaire
indispensable sur ce plan stratégique
national
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur marc fesneau ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs
les députés monsieur le député
prud'hommes votre question me permettra
de compléter les précédentes si je peux
dire d'abord contesté le point que vous
avez évoquées y'a pas d'agri bashing
fantasmer monsieur minot a eu raison de
le souligner tout à l'heure il ya un
certain nombre d'agriculteurs qui sont
victimes d'agressions chine ce n'est pas
fantasmer c'est des choses qui existent
aller sur des exploitations agricoles
discuter avec des agriculteurs qui sont
parfois mais la menace est au pied du
champ pour des raisons ajusté vous
verrez s'il ya pas d'aghrib achim
fantasmer je vous propose que
collectivement nous essayons de pas y
rentrer deuxièmement vous dites qu'il
faut des instances démocratiques pour
parler du budget de la pac que je vous
rappelle quand même d'ailleurs vous y
avait des députés européens qui a
parlement européen qui va des pôles
débattent de la pac et qu'ici aussi nous
pourrons en discuter mais respectons
aussi les institutions démocratiques
dans laquelle vous même vous avez
demandé à être élu il paraît que c'est
une chose importante
la troisième chose que voulait dire les
outils de la pac à quoi elle doit servir
au fond là dessus je peux être assez
d'accord et le gouvernement est assez
d'accord avec vous il ya un certain
nombre d'outils la pac elle doit
garantir d'abord un revenu pour les
agriculteurs et donc à doit leur
garantir des éléments qui leur
permettent d'améliorer leur
compétitivité et leur productivité
la pac il faut pas oublier son fondement
non plus elle avait été faite
elle avait été faite par les pères
fondateurs de l'europe et par ceux qui
confondent l apec pour nourrir il ne
faut jamais s'écarter de la question
quantitative et je pense que ça serait
une erreur de dire que nous n'allons pas
y compris avec le changement climatique
des vrais enjeux quantitatif au gré des
aléas climatiques nous faisons et puis
le deuxième sujet pour ne pas être trop
long le deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de
la transition vous avez raison il ya
besoin de mener des transition
écologique
il ya besoin de mesures mais arrêtez de
parler de france statégique je vous
parle de la pac la pâte c'est un plan
stratégique la pâte c'est un plan
stratégique
s'il n'y a pas les outils de la pac
c'est pour ça que nous défendons ce
budget avec cette force la cia passé
budget de la pac
il n'y aura pas de politique agricole
etc les agriculteurs français qui en
souffriront plus si vous re propos si
vous proposez la nationalisation de la
pac
je pense que vous faites une grave
erreur mais ça n'empêche pas que nous en
parlions ici mais il ya besoin de faire
évoluer un certain nombre d'outils et
c'est à ça que servir à la pac merci
monsieur merci monsieur le ministre la
parole au top et à madame nicole sans
coeur
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse taux au ministre de
l'intérieur
si le haut commissaire de la république
en polynésie française a indiqué le mois
dernier que la délinquance est contenue
sur notre territoire
il a toutefois pointé du doigt les
priorités en la matière à savoir la
lutte contre les drogues la lutte contre
les violences familiales et la poursuite
des actions de prévention et de
répression pour la sécurité routière
vous n'ignorez pas monsieur le ministre
que l'après-midi française est un des
territoires les plus touchés par les
violences intrafamiliales et que le taux
d'infractions à la législation sur les
stupéfiants pour 1000 habitants est deux
fois supérieur à celui de l'hexagone
d'ailleurs madame liste des outre-mer en
mission il ya quinze jours en polynésie
française avait déclaré la guerre à la
drogue de synthèse qui fait des ravages
sur nos cibles il ne passe pas une
semaine sans qu'une saisine soit réalisé
ces chiffres témoignent de l'ampleur du
fléau auquel nous douaniers nos
policiers doivent faire face cependant
il souffre d'un sous-effectif et
souhaite mener à bien leur mission de
contrôle et de surveillance maritime et
terrestre avec plus de renforts humains
de plus nos tribunaux connaissent un
accroissement du nombre de comparutions
immédiates pour vos couleurs aux
engorgements
pour faire suite aux assises
territoriales de la sécurité intérieure
en outre-mer qui donneront lieu à la
parution du livre blanc de la sécurité
intérieure des premières annonces ont
été faites le 13 février dans le sens
d'un renforcement de la sécurité en
martinique avec l'envoyé l'envoi de
moyens supplémentaires
à cette occasion monsieur le ministre
vous nous avez rappelé que la sécurité
intérieure en outre-mer est une priorité
de votre action
ces mots sont forts et je me réjouis que
vous exprimiez toute la considération
que méritent les outre-mer mais pour
passer des paroles aux actes
nous avons grand besoin de moyens
supplémentaires en polynésie française
qu'entendez vous mettre en oeuvre
monsieur le ministre pour pallier le
manque de moyens en matière de sécurité
intérieure et à quelle échéance je
voudrais merci chers collègues la parole
de monsieur christophe questionnaire
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs 10 pts
et madame la députée
vous avez raison il ya une particularité
sur le phénomène délinquants ciel que
connaît la polynésie
aujourd'hui nous sommes en deçà sur
l'ensemble des phénomènes délinquants
ciel de ce que nous connaissons en outre
mer mais nous avons dans le territoire
dont vous représentez ici la population
deux fléaux celui des violences
intrafamiliales et celui du trafic de
drogue et du trafic de stupéfiants je
voudrais vous préciser madame la députée
l'attention toute particulière que nous
portons à la fois la sécurité
globalement concernant la polynésie mais
aussi sur ces sujets là nous avons ainsi
fait progresser de 18 le nombre
d'effectifs de policiers et de gendarmes
qui sont mobilisés sur le territoire
nous avons maintenu aussi un escadron en
permanence plus liés à la gestion de
l'ordre public chaque fois que c'est
nécessaire mais qui porte aussi son
assistance à l'ensemble de nos forces
qui agissent sur le sujet et pourtant
malgré cela nous voyons que il y a
toujours un très haut niveau de trafic
et en particulier de stupéfiants même si
nous avons pu constater ces dernières
deux dernières années une vraie
progression
une vraie progression en matière de
résultats ainsi six cent cinquante trois
affaires ont été traitées l'année
dernière contre 459 l'année précédente
et pour 2019 je vous ferai parvenir un
bilan précis total qui n'est pas au
moment où je vous parle totalement
actualisé mais je pense qu'il est
important que vous preniez connaissance
pour illustrer cela en 2009 ce sont plus
de 10 kg de stupéfiants de type ice
vous savez cette drogue chimique qui est
produite essentiellement au départ au
japon et qui aujourd'hui est diffusée
largement et qui produit des dégâts
extrêmement grave il nous faut madame la
députée aller plus loin et c'est le sens
des 55 mesures du plan national de lutte
contre les stupéfiants qui doit se
décliner localement en polynésie pour
prendre en compte la réalité
géographique de ce trafic qui pour
l'origine des produits vient
essentiellement d'australie et des états
unis mais qui vient aussi d'amérique du
sud et sur lequel nous devons développer
des mesures spécifiques je vous propose
madame la députée sur la base de la
communication des chiffres que je vous
ferai parvenir que nous puissions évoqué
cela je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre la parole de monsieur patrick
deux heures merci beaucoup monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
alors que la cour des comptes
énonce aujourd'hui un redressement des
comptes publics qui est à l'arrêt alors
que la dette publique atteint les 100%
du pib
menaçant notre souveraineté en nous
mettant dans les mains de nos créanciers
alors que vous condamnez les générations
futures a payé le prix de votre refus du
moindre effort budgétaire
nous venons d'apprendre que vous aviez
l'intention de nommer à la tête de la
cour des comptes et du haut conseil des
finances publiques
une personne qui n'a aucune compétence
en la matière c'est du jamais vu
en somme le gouvernement se préoccupe
davantage du sort de ses amis à recaser
que de l'avenir de nos comptes publics
vous faites passer la connivence avant
la compétence
nos seules premier ministre pourquoi
avez-vous aussi peu de considération
pour nos institutions
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi
négligez vous h point la france et ses
comptes publics
merci la parole est à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre chargé de l'action et
des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le député je
pensais que vous avez posé question sur
les comptes publics
je m'aperçois qu'on fasse des attaques
ad hominem je pense que sinon ce qui
peut vous répondre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre en arrivant
au pouvoir vous faisiez des promesses
aux français vous disiez que rien ne
serait comme avant que dans le nouveau
monde il n'y aurait pas de copinage que
la compétence l'emporterait avant tout
force est de constater que votre nouveau
monde c'est l'ancien en bien pire
on ne compte plus le nombre de ministres
qui ont quitté le gouvernement pour des
affaires on ne compte plus les
turpitudes à tous les étages de votre
majorité ou et la france dans tout cela
ce ministre alors c'est un peu le
problème monsieur députés quand on écrit
la réponse à vendre avant d'avoir
entendu la réponse du ministre c'est
qu'on est complètement c'est qu'au bleu
c'est koné c'est qu'on est monsieur
débuté c'est connu c'est qu'on est
monsieur le député complètement hors
sujet vous en êtes à commenter des
rumeurs a attaqué personnellement des
membres du gouvernement
il me semblait que dans votre nom le
parti que vous présentiez c'était les
républicains mal au républicanisme
monsieur députés ce n'est pas d'insultés
ce n'est pas d'abord ce n'est pas de
s'énerver c'est très mauvais pour le
coeur ce n'est pas de s'exciter
ce n'est pas de crier et si vous n'aviez
pas lu votre papier quand je vous ai
apporté ma réponse qui consiste à paray
des comptes publics vous auriez
peut-être eu des réponses qui concernait
les comptes publics
en plus ce que vous avez dit monsieur le
député est particulièrement faux nous
n'avons pas atteint 100% de la dette
nous avons diminué le déficit à 2,2 pour
cent du déficit est d'ailleurs monsieur
le député je me suis permis avec bruno
le maire de vous faire la photocopie de
la lettre que nous avons répondu au
président de la cour des comptes dont je
pensais que c'était l'objet de votre
question vous étiez attachés aux comptes
publics
malheureusement et si j'ose dire avec
beaucoup de regret je m'aperçois que ce
qui vous intéresse c'est de commenter
des rumeurs de façon tout à fait
malveillantes sont par ailleurs sont par
ailleurs monsieur le député
mais je sais que les je sais je sais que
les campagnes électorales énerve
[Applaudissements]
mais il faut savoir prendre son temps
respirez par le nez soufflé par la
bouche et ça va bien se passer si
monsieur les lui s'ils veulent bien lui
donner une copie de ce courrier je suis
certain que vous lirez avec attention ce
qui vous permettra sans doute de poser
une question la prochaine fois mes chers
collègues comme ce sujet vous passionne
je vous signale que d après des
questions au gouvernement le rapport
annuel de la cour des comptes sera
présentée et je compte sur votre
présence pour me sentir un peu moins
seul qu'à l'accoutumée et ceci vaut pour
tout le monde ici la parole à monsieur
charles de courson
ma question s'adresse au ministre au
pluriel de l'intérieur et de
l'agriculture
messieurs les ministres l'inquiétude des
exploitants agricoles et viticoles
devant le blocage des discussions ce
futur budget de la politique agricole
commune se double d'une exaspération
devant la multiplication des vols de
toutes natures gps tracteur carburant
etc
pour prendre un exemple dans la nuit du
31 janvier au 1er février un drame s'est
produit à ambrières petites communes
marnaises située dans la circonscription
jean louis leroux agriculteurs de cette
commune a été victime de plus de
cinquante cambriolages dans les cinq
dernières années
vous entendez bien médecine ministre
cinquante cambriolages dont quatre
depuis le 1er janvier
et cette nuit là dès le déclenchement de
l'alarmé il a contacté les forces de
gendarmerie puis il s'est rendu au
devant des cambrioleurs accompagné de
son frère
hélas alors que les deux frères tentait
de retenir les malfaiteurs dans la tente
de la gendarmerie
un coup de feu est parti et a blessé
grièvement l'un des trois jeunes voleurs
sans que jean-louis l'euro ait eu
l'intention de blesser quiconque
devant un tel drame qui aurait pu
survenir à n'importe quel endroit de
notre territoire national quelle mesure
comprendre le gouvernement pour éviter
que d'autres drames de cette nature ne
survienne
d'autre part le gouvernement peut-il
faire le point devant la représentation
nationale sur l'état des négociations
relatives au budget de l'union
européenne et en particulier sur le
budget de la politique
grifols comique merci monsieur débuté la
parole à monsieur christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames sur les dites
monsieur le député charles de courson
vous avez raison d'évoquer ces tensions
ces tensions permanentes que subit le
monde agricole et notamment du fait de
vols divers dont ils peuvent faire
l'objet l'année dernière en 2019 ce sont
7000 500 faits de vols et plus de 1600
cambriolages qui ont touché
spécifiquement le monde agricole
quelquefois à travers définir organisé
et vous avez évoqué par exemple les vols
de gps et je voudrais du coup salué le
travail de nos forces notamment
judiciaire de la gendarmerie nationale
qui ont il ya peu de temps démantelé un
réseau international avec des
ressortissants lituaniens et qui avait
fait procéder au vol de près de 700 gps
pour un coût global qui représentait
près de 5 millions d'euros
on voit comment on a une criminalité
internationale qui est organisé et des
vols qui se multiplient qu'il s'agisse
de matériel mais aussi d'animaux voire
de production agricole et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous faut agir
sur ce sujet se rajoute à cela des
intrusions près d'un millier d'actions
liées à la cause environnementale
parfaitement légitime dans la discussion
mais elle n'est pas légitime quant à
elle enfreint les règles de loi que vous
votez ici on procédait l'année dernière
à cette mise en cause un peu
systématique du monde agricole est là
aussi ce sont des violences des
violences que subissent le monde
agricole est quelquefois les animaux
eux-mêmes
compte tenu de pertes lourdes qui ont
été constatés dans le cadre de ces
opérations la ce que je vais vous dire
mesdames messieurs les députés c'est
qu'évidemment cela est inacceptable et
qu'évidemment nous devons être
totalement mobilisés d'abord nos forces
et la gendarmerie en particulier le sont
près de 2000 gendarmes sont spécialisés
aujourd'hui dans l'accompagnement du
monde agricole
non pas à ton plein mais dans
l'accompagnement du monde agricole pour
faire en sorte qu'une meilleure sécurité
puissent être garanties pour que des
communications directes puissent avoir
lieu
et puis vous le savez il ya quelques
mois et j'ai encore présenter cela hier
au salon de l'agriculture nous allons
créer une cellule dédiée demeter au sein
de la gendarmerie nationale pour
améliorer notre coordination avec le
monde agricole et pour améliorer encore
la protection que nous devons
légitimement au monde agricole
je ne répond pas à la question
concernant le budget de la pac mais je
crois que un certain nombre de ministres
premiers seront plus aujourd'hui se
prononcer sur le sujet le député
monsieur le ministre
l'opération demeter monsieur leroux il
avait en liaison avec la gendarmerie et
qui paie sa ferme puisqu'il a dit t'es
pas dans la ferme de caméras l'essai
grâce à ses caméras qui sont déclenchées
qu'il est venu qu il averti tout de
suite avant d'y aller
la gendarmerie mais qui est arrivé un
peu après eux puisqu'ils ont un temps de
trajet plus important donc si vous
voulez la réponse que vous faites
elle n'est pas satisfaisante parce que
les agriculteurs viticulteurs
ils ont vraiment le sentiment qui a plus
d'état merci monsieur le député la
parole à monsieur jean pour lui fraigne
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre idéal c'est le nom de
cette magnifique vaches charolaises
égérie du salon international de
l'agriculture
cette race avec la limousine la blonde
d'aquitaine ou encore l'aubrac
constituent la majeure partie du
troupeau allaitant
ce sont des animaux élevés pour leur
viande de haute qualité
porté par la coopérative sica bas le
premier label rouge en viande bovine
adulte est né en 1974 dans ma
circonscription de l'allier en plein
coeur du bocage bourbonnais ces animaux
pâture sur des prairies dit naturel
c'est à dire jamais labourer et qui
participe à la biodiversité à laquelle
nous sommes tous attachés
ces exploitations d'élevage sont souvent
situés en zones dites défavorisées
simples et ne peuvent pas prétendre au
même niveau dette que les exploitations
en zones de montagne par exemple ce mode
d'élevage est aujourd'hui menacé le
moral n'y est plus même le député moreau
le disais au salon ce week-end il faut
intervenir le plus vite possible
notamment au niveau de l'élevage bovin
viande où il y a un gros souci de prix
de vente et qui n'est plus du tout en
phase avec les coûts de production dans
mon département et dans d'autres de plus
en plus d'éleveurs jette l'épongé et
vendre leur cheptel
les prairies seront labourées contre
nature la loi et galim avait suscité de
l'espoir elle n'est malheureusement pas
au rendez vous
de plus les premières discussions autour
de la future pac ne sont pas
encourageantes
ma question est simple monsieur le
premier ministre avez vous la volonté de
sauver l'élevage bovin allaitant en
france et comment ou bien allez vous
comme dans d'autres domaines
laisser faire le marché et continuer de
signer des traités ou les distorsions de
concurrence ne sont pas acceptables
comme les que les députés communistes le
dénonce régulièrement
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jean paul
dufrègne labourage et pâturage sont les
deux mamelles de la france et personne
ici ne pourrait imaginer la france sont
l'une ou sans l'autre personne ne
pourrait imaginer la france sans la
charolaise sur l'aubrac sont là rouge
des prés sur la blonde d'aquitaine sans
la salers et sans la limousine et sans
la normande je voudrais garder un tout
petit peu de temps pour répondre à votre
question mais je reconnais bien
volontiers que aujourd'hui sera-ce les
éleveurs qui les élèves sont confrontés
à des difficultés absolument
considérable les difficultés de prix des
difficultés naturelles et difficultés
avec le rat taupier sur les prairies
naturelles qui est un phénomène sur
lequel nous avons beaucoup lutté depuis
plusieurs années et surtout un prix de
vente qui est insuffisant et je suis le
premier à reconnaître que la loi et
galim qu'a donné d'excellents résultats
sur beaucoup beaucoup de sujets sur la
question de la rémunération des banques
des éleveurs bovins allaitants ne
donnent pas les résultats attendus et
qu'aujourd'hui les prix ne sont pas au
rendez vous pour des éleveurs qui sont à
la peine qu'ils n'ont pas les revenus
qui devraient avoir qui font un travail
exceptionnel qui produisent des bêtes de
qualité que chacun put voir prochant
l'agriculture et qui n'ont pas la juste
rémunération de leurs efforts la réponse
c'est quoi la première c est une
meilleure organisation de la filière
je m'y étais employés dans d'autres
fonctions il ya quelques années le
travail reste encore important à faire
la deuxième c'est revoir dans la loi et
galim ce qui mérite d'être revu
précisément pour les éleveurs bovins
allaitants nous y sommes prêts avec
didier guillaume pour améliorer le texte
et faire en sorte que les contrats
soient plus fortes et que les éleveurs
puissent être mieux rémunérés la
troisième réponse elle tient évidemment
à la politique agricole commune nous
sommes prêts à ce qu'il y ait des
mesures spécifiques le présent la
république l'a dit et se bat pour cela
pour les secteurs qui sont les plus
menacés et je mets au premier rang de
ces secteurs dans l'agriculture
française
les éleveurs bovins allaitants merci
monsieur le ministre c'est des frênes
c'est pour saluer la pie noir bretonne
j'imagine avec plaisir monsieur le
président merci monsieur le merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir reconnu les
difficultés particulières de ce secteur
et je redis qu'il y a urgence parce que
actuellement le moral effectivement n'y
est pas il y a trop de disparités de
disparitions d'exploitations merci qui
seront merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame marguerite deprez
audebert merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame le ministre
du travail madame la ministre
les chiffres de l'emploi s'améliore
globalement mais il ya encore des poches
de résistance et nous allons rentrer
dans le dur
le combat pour lutter contre le chômage
à plusieurs armes
l'innovation fait partie et vous en êtes
convaincu j'en suis sûr madame la
ministre
dans ma région des hauts de france où le
chômage est encore trop élevé malgré une
amélioration sensible en 2019 et où des
postes sont malgré tout à pourvoir les
services publics de l'emploi local spel
et la ligue d'athlétisme ont organisé un
job dating plutôt innovant et efficace
vendredi dernier au stade de liévin dans
le pas de calais a eu lieu la deuxième
édition de l'opération du stade vers
l'emploi des demandeurs d'emploi des
recruteurs potentiels se sont rencontrés
anonymement lors d'épreuves sportives
avant de se présenter pour de véritables
entretiens d'embauché
la perspective du boom économique que
devrait créer les jo de paris n'est pas
seule à l'origine de cet événement
auquel vous avez assisté mm participer
madame la nuit
ce premier contact à travers le sport
permet une sensibilisation au respect
des règles du collectif du partenaire au
dépassement de soi
autant de valeurs inhérentes aux sports
cette rencontre a été également
l'occasion de faire connaître aux
demandeurs d'emploi des métiers ignorer
ou en tension cette opération
d'inclusion par le sport était destiné à
des candidats plutôt jeunes peu ou pas
diplômés peu familier des stades issus
de territoires parfois oubliés elle leur
a permis d'être repéré par leur
comportement ou leur savoir-être souvent
aussi important que les compétences
un an après la première édition près de
75 participations participant à cette
opération avait trouvé un emploi
madame la ministre de telles actions
n'aurait-elle pas vocation à se
multiplier dans l'hexagone quels autres
initiatives innovantes seriez vous prête
à encourager je vous remercie
merci la parole était madame muriel
pénicaud ministre du travail monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée marguerite
deprez audebert oui merci de votre
présence près de moi à liévin vendredi
clairement le sport fait partie des
leviers pour l'emploi ça permet de
casser les codes classiques du
recrutement se permet de redonner
confiance en soi et déceler les
potentiels alors oui l'innovation fait
partie des armes de lutte contre le
chômage
le chômage baisse se lâche baisse
beaucoup dans votre département en deux
ans on est passé de 11 6 à 10 2 % de
chômage mais c'est encore beaucoup et
même s'il ya plus de cdi que jamais un
taux d'emploi meilleur que jamais un
taux d'apprentissage meilleur que jamais
nous devons laisser personne au bord du
chemin
alors il ya beaucoup d'innovations le
même jour on nous a présenté à niort 4
lots votre collègue une innovation très
intéressante qu'elle fait dans le nord
et le sport fait partie de ces leviers
alors grâce au soutien du ministère du
travail et du comité des jeux olympiques
2024 cette expérimentation qui a été
lancée dans le nord et qu'on a auquel on
a participé à liévin va pouvoir se
multiplier puisque on va le faire dans
70 villes
c'est extraordinaire de voir à quel
point on arrive à quatre embauches sur
cinq
juste en changeant complètement le
regard entre recruteurs et demandeurs
d'emploi
et je crois que ça donne de l'espoir sur
le fait qu'il faut recruter sur les
compétences sur le potentiel sur la
motivation et pas simplement sur le cv
alors il ya d'autres expérimentations
dans le domaine du sport et dans le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
ont fait des expérimentations
on finance tout championnes et champions
en plaine saint denis sport dans la
ville à partir de lyon l' agence du
sport qui a fait tout un travail sur le
recrutement des invisibles en
travaillant avec les animateurs sportifs
dans les apprentissages la fédération
française du rugby vient avec la comité
d'organisation de la coupe du monde de
rugby vient de lancer assez fort comme
le foot à montpellier où lui ses pairs
et avec la ministre des sports nous
serons le 24 mars au salon de
l'alternance dans le sport et encourager
toutes ces innovations qui peuvent eux
être dans les outils de litres contre le
chômage merci d'un ministre la parole
est à mme adame ba t-il de panneaux
monsieur le premier ministre
héberger des punaises de lit est un
calvaire elle empêche de dormir
elle mord douloureusement elle épuise
elle use les nerfs à devenir fou pour
les contenir j'ai prévenu ma famille mon
entourage et n'ai plus reçu d'amis chez
moi ni ne me suis rendu chez eux cet
enfer quotidien et celui de centaines de
milliers de familles dans notre pays
depuis huit mois notre groupe
parlementaire vous demande aux côtés de
l'association droit au logement de la
confédération nationale du logement de
l'association nationale de défense des
consommateurs et de l'intercollectif de
marseille de reconnaître les punaises de
lit comme un problème de santé publique
nous avons fait une manifestation signer
des pétitions fait du porte-à-porte
d'information aider des familles à
désinsectiser leur logement demandé des
rendez vous auprès du ministère de la
santé et celui du logement écrit une
proposition de résolution
huit mois après vous commencez à vous
saisir du problème enfants mais la
déception est à la hauteur des attentes
un site internet un numéro de téléphone
payant et une mission parlementaire
pourtant les solutions on les connaît
lorsque le nombre de logements infestés
explose
lorsque les punaises de lit prolifèrent
dans tous les lieux du quotidien les
hôpitaux écoles bibliothèques résidence
étudiante maison de retraite prison
train ou même les salles de cinéma il
faut agir d'urgence
qu'attendez vous pour reconnaître ce
fléau des punaises de lit comme un
problème de santé publique
qu'attendez vous pour interdire les
insecticides des entreprises privées
vendues à prix d'or inefficace et nocive
pour la santé et l'environnement
il faut arrêter cette course cupide dans
lequel le gain s'obtient à partir du
malheur des gens qu'attendez vous pour
mettre de l'argent sur la table pour
lutter contre les punaises de lit à
l'échelle du pays
merci madame panneaux la parole d'un
homme jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la députée pour votre
question c'est en effet un fléau qui
touche tous types d'habitat des
logements neufs comme des logements
anciens et vous l'avez rappelé aussi ces
punaises se déplace facilement dans les
vieux meubles dans les valises et elles
peuvent effectivement se trouvaient
également dans des lieux publics comme
les cinémas
le gouvernement a donc lancé le 21
février un plan de prévention et de
lutte contre les punaises de lit dans
l'habitat vous l'aurez qu'elle amiez
c'est vrai vous réclamiez un plan
d'urgence en la matière et vous aviez
d'ailleurs été reçus par le cabinet de
julia de normandie sur le sujet le
mystère le ministère pardon a voulu en
faire un moment fort pour informer les
particuliers sur le risque d'un fait
station de leur logement avec
effectivement une campagne relayée sur
les réseaux sociaux est également un
site qui a été ouvert depuis quelques
jours et qui a eu déjà seize mille
visites ce qui prouve évidemment son
utilité par ailleurs un accord a été
signé vendredi dernier avec les
représentants de la filière de la
désinsectisation et bien évidemment tous
les particuliers pourront d'ici la fin
de l'année faire appel à des
prestataires qualifiés et certifiés
il faut aussi que l'on se préoccupe du
coût des traitements qui peut être
dissuasif pour une partie de la
population
c'est la raison pour laquelle la députée
katia combinaison sera prochainement
missionné pour aborder toutes les
questions que soulève ce sujet aussi
bien les aspects jeu technique
organisationnel juridique mais aussi
financier des échanges ont lieu déjà
avec les assureurs
et se poursuivent dans cette perspective
et dans le cas de ces travaux la députée
nous fera des propositions adaptées à la
situation des ménages et de cette
situation de fléau
je le rappelle merci mon amour ou madame
pinault
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons un gouvernement avec une
politique coordonnée pas une centrale
d'appel le ministe de normandie nous
avait reçus
il a fait part à la presse qu'il avait
été touché personnellement par les
punaises de lit la ministre busan a
toujours refusé de nous recevoir
alors faut-il espérer que matignon soit
infesté par les punaises de lit pour que
vous traitiez enfin avec sérieux qu'il
mérite ce sujet merci madame prenant la
parole comme monsieur frédéric reiss
merci monsieur le président en l'absence
de monsieur ministre de l'éducation
nationale j'adresse ma question à
monsieur le premier ministre les e3
c'est ont cristallisé un malaise profond
dans l'éducation nationale et le
ministre vient d'ailleurs de répondre
sur les failles des épreuves communes de
contrôle continu
de fait c'est toute la réforme du
baccalauréat qui inquiète les élèves les
familles et les enseignants les attendus
du supérieur peu explicite le grand oral
et de nouvelles inégalités sont autant
de facteurs d'inquiétude de cette
réforme stressante des élèves cèdent à
des crises d angoisse l'abandon d'une
spécialité en terminale provoque des
choix cornéliens chez les élèves et
représente un réel casse tête pour les
chefs d'établissement dans une mission
flash avec ma collègue géraldine banier
nous avons relevé que la carte des
spécialités demeure peu accessibles aux
élèves et à leurs parents
car tous les établissements n'ont pas
les 11 spécialités
nous proposons de rendre possible le
maintien de trois spécialités en
terminale et d'intégrer des
mathématiques dans le tronc commun
l'option mathématiques complémentaire
financée comme toutes les options par
les lycées sur leurs dotations propre
n'est pas la solution
je crains fort qu'il y ait de mauvaises
surprises en terminale avec peu de
moyens pour une deuxième option et un
coup fatal porté aux langues anciennes
aux langues régionales ou encore aux
sciences de l'ingénieur monsieur le
premier ministre la réforme
bénéficiera-t-elle d'ajustement suite
difficultés constatées et à madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député frédéric reiss tout
d'abord permettez-moi d'excusés jean
michel blanquer qui est actuellement
avec le président de la république en
réunion de travail avec des associations
nationales de l'éducation populaire vous
interrogez le ministère de l'éducation
nationale sur la réforme du bac est en
fait je voudrais ici rappeler ce qui a
guidé toutes les transformations que
nous avons menée conjointement avec jean
michel blanc coeur permettre aux élèves
de construire un projet qui leur
ressemble et lutter contre l'échec en
licence avec parcours sup et avec la
réforme délaissé accompagner les élèves
dans la conception de ce projet lutter
résolument contre l'autocensure et
accompagner toute notre jeunesse dans
ses choix et dans la construction de
leur projet de formation dans cette
perspective vous le savez un bach
couperin bach bachotage n'avait pas de
sens c'est pourquoi du contrôle continu
a été introduit dans les épreuves de
baccalauréat et je pense que c'est
effectivement quelque chose d'essentiel
de très important de même que le grand
oral qui en réalité permettra que chacun
des futurs bacheliers soit capable de
prendre la parole en public et je crois
que c'est essentiel pour tout le monde
les séries d'épreuves de contrôle
continu ont eu lieu parfois elles ont
été perturbées mais uniquement là où
certains avaient décidé de mettre le
désordre sont aujourd'hui quasiment
terminée il ne reste que 5 % de ces
épreuves qui doivent encore être passés
est ce à dire qu'il n'y a pas d
inquiétude légitime bien sûr que non et
c'est pourquoi jean michel blanc car a
souhaité un comité de suivi de cette
réforme pour proposer des évolutions et
ce comité se tiendra dès le courant du
mois de mars
notre objectif est de faire travailler
et
réussir les élèves dans la formation je
remercie merci monsieur le député oui
madame la ministre la réforme s'applique
dans la douleur un enseignant de mon
département qui pensent sérieusement
quitté l'éducation nationale déclare je
le cite du fait des dernières réformes
aux paramètres très flou je ressens une
totale perte de sens je suis usé certain
s'effondre mois j'abdique fin de
citation madame la ministre
il est temps de redonner le moral à ses
enseignants qui se dévoue corps et âme
pour notre jeunesse et la réforme des
retraites ne contribue pas à les
rassurer
merci la parole est à monsieur françois
jolivet merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur ministre de l'économie des
finances monsieur ministre préserver
augmenter le reste à vis des français
une préoccupation du gouvernement et
c'est d'ailleurs à ce titre que fin 2018
sous votre impulsion
vous avez souhaité que les banques
s'engagent pour limiter leurs frais
bancaires